Musik
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Headset entwirre nochmal kurz.
So.
Excellent.
So, genug gehadbanged.
So.
Excellent.
So, genug gehadbanked.
Machen wir ein bisschen was Entspannteres an.
Äh.
Nein.
Das ist auch nice, aber das kann ich jetzt nicht drei Stunden Endlosschleife laufen lassen.
Sekunde, Leute.
Irgendwas.
Ich hab wieder irgendwas verkackt bei meinem Headset. Sekunde.
Ja, jetzt. Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt.
Das stimmt nicht. Ich bin da.
So Leute, heute Hardcore Rust Broggers
Stels
Ich hab zwar was
Bestimmtes vor, aber
Wir müssen erstmal ein bisschen in Rust
Wieder reinkommen und ein bisschen rumgucken und basteln
Also so wirklich
Da irgendwas
Abschließen werden wir heute wahrscheinlich nicht können
Ja
Mein Ziel ist ja immer noch
Über USB was auszulesen
Aber das letzte Mal
irgendwas mehr schlecht als recht in Go
zusammengestrickt.
Wir machen das jetzt low-level
selbst in Rust. Und natürlich, weil es Rust ist,
Leute, wie war das?
Laserspeed,
sagt man jetzt, gell?
Blazingly Fast is out. Laserspeed.
Wieso nicht Swift?
Wieso nicht
Erlang?
Oder
Objective C
oder Fortran
oder Kobol
Also ich kenne
wenige Games, die so eine
catchy Soundtrack haben,
wie vvvvvvvv.
Wie viele Vsatz?
vvvvvv.
Habe ich die Lautstärke
hier richtig eingestellt? Ja. Das weißt du bei
Windows ja nie, weil Windows immer zwischen den Streams
Zeug verstellt.
Und ja, ich gebe zu,
es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt die
beste Zeit zum Streamen, weil jetzt
viele Leute auf dem Heimweg sind, aber was willst
du machen, ne?
Gerade viele
Leute schon fertig mit der Arbeit, fahren jetzt heim.
Twitch sagt gerade,
ich soll in 1440p
streamen. Das ist viel geiler.
Das Ding ist nur,
warum sollte ich in 1440p
streamen, wenn ich noch mit 1080p
capture?
Das macht wenig Sinn, oder?
Oder Twitch.
Besos möchte wahrscheinlich, dass ich mir bei Amazon neue Sachen bestelle.
Ich...
Das kann übrigens tatsächlich sein,
dass ich in nicht allzu langer Zeit
1440p streamen werde.
Muss mal grad ein bisschen was Entspannendes anmachen jetzt.
Kann nämlich tatsächlich fast sein,
weil...
Schauen wir mal, ob hier irgendwas
Entspannendes dabei ist.
Weil ich schon eine ganze Weile am überlegen bin, wie es mal langsam mit einem neuen OLED-Bildschirm wäre.
Und nachdem es ja mittlerweile auch, wie soll man es nennen, Gaming-OLED-Bildschirme gibt,
also halt irgendwas mit 240 Hertz plus OLED oder sowas, ich glaube es gibt sogar schon 360 Hertz OLED oder sowas,
da bin ich ernsthaft am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht sowas kaufen soll.
Das einzig Dumme ist, diese Monitore sind halt teuer.
Und ich weiß halt nicht, ob es sich lohnt, wirklich nur, weil ich es haben will, letztendlich, sag mal, kann das mal anfangen, please, jetzt anzugehen, nur weil ich es haben will, mir jetzt irgendwie für 1500 Euro oder so einen neuen Monitor zu kaufen.
16 zu 9 oder ein bisschen breiter
Naja, dadurch, dass die meisten Leute
bei 16 zu 9 gucken
wäre 16 zu 9
eigentlich am besten
Wobei ich halt nicht weiß, ob es die Dinger überhaupt
16 zu 9 gibt
Ah, das klingt schon deutlich entspannender
Mal ein bisschen weiter
Exzellent
Also deswegen, ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Ich muss aber auch jetzt wirklich sagen,
ich habe gar keinen Bock, mich so richtig damit zu beschäftigen.
Weil ich bin mit meinem Setup eigentlich ziemlich happy, so wie es ist.
Ja, weil ich, guck mal, ich capture in 1080p, ich streame in 1080p, ich arbeite und dingse hier in 1080p, ich capture den anderen Mini-PC in 1080p, 240fps, da müsste ich das upscalen und sowas und ah, keine Ahnung.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe echt keine Ahnung, ob sich das lohnt. Einfach nur wegen dem will ich haben Faktor. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das lohnt.
So, äh, Moment.
Was mache ich denn hier eigentlich?
Warum mache ich meine VM an?
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich will meine VM nicht anmachen.
Ich will den Mini-PC einschalten.
Linux Mini-PC.
Run in Normal Mode.
Ah, yes.
Ich muss für RAM sparen.
Ich brauche keinen RAM. Ich habe 64 GB RAM.
Ach, du meinst für den Mini-PC.
Für den Mini-PC könnte ich sogar noch aus einem der Nassgeräte was rausmachen.
Also ich hätte sogar theoretisch noch.
Vielleicht machen wir das jetzt auch.
Weil ich muss ja gleich wieder IDE und alles aufmachen.
Und das braucht wieder so viel RAM.
Gucken wir mal.
Oh, wichtig.
Leute, gerne mal am Tastatur.
Dieses Passwort, da kommt ihr eh nicht drauf.
Passt mal auf hier.
Fünf Buchstaben.
Highly secure.
Du hast eine Sekretärin?
Nicht schlecht.
Deswegen hast du auch immer so viel Zeit.
Du bist der große Chef.
So, jetzt machen wir erstmal Update.
und, Alter, wie viel Zeug von VLC
wird denn hier gerade aktualisiert?
Das halbe Internet.
Und was ist, was ist
Enchant?
Enchant heißt sowas, die verzaubern oder so.
Enchant.
Rapper Library for generic
Spellchecking. Ah ja.
Alles klar. Okay. Yes.
Wups, wer drückt?
Yes.
Und jetzt noch.
Our Packages.
Nix. Okay.
Und wie sieht es mit Jetbrains Packages aus?
Was wir da updaten?
Uh, Rastrover wird geupdatet.
Passend zum Stream heute.
Dass wir noch blazingly faster sind.
Und seht ihr das?
Wie geil ist das?
Wie gesagt, mir geht da immer voll einer drauf ab.
Wenn ich meine wobbly Windows sehe.
Guck mal, wie das wobbelt.
Und ihr seht das noch nicht mal in voller Pracht
Ihr seht das nur mit 48 FPS
Ich seh das bei mir mit 240 FPS
Das sieht noch viel geiler aus mit 240 FPS
Bei euch sieht es ja fast schon ein bisschen ruckelig aus
Aber für mich ist das hier
Butterweiches wobbly Windows
So, Update ist fertig
Mal ein bisschen Rastrover geupdatet ist
Gibt es das für Windows?
Nee, es gab mal vor langer Zeit, es gab mal sowas wie Compits für Windows.
Für Windows XP gab es das mal irgendwann.
Das da?
Meine ich das?
Das könnte sein.
Aber wie gesagt, das gab es nur für Windows XP oder so.
Ja, genau.
Das gibt es, glaube ich, für Windows.
Tatsächlich, es gibt es mittlerweile für Windows 11.
So was hier.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das sind irgendwelche komischen Zusatzdinger,
die wahrscheinlich übel sacken unter Windows.
Und unter Linux ist das einfach besser.
GPU-Usage.
Wir können mal gucken, wie die GPU-Usage ist.
Lass mal ausprobieren.
Guck mal hier.
Wir machen jetzt einfach NV-Top.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, was die GPU-Usage macht während Wobbly Windows.
Okay.
Na, guck mal.
28% GPU-Usage und das ist eine Mobile-AMD-Grafikkarte.
Guck mal, so viel wobbeln können wir gar nicht, dass das ordentlich nennenswerte GPU-Auslastung verursacht.
Oh, nix.
Nix verursacht das großartig.
29%.
Geworbelt.
So, jetzt haben wir geupdatet.
Chat, was heißt das?
Was heißt das, wenn wir geupdatet haben?
Was kommt jetzt?
Ihr werdet es erraten haben.
Reboot.
Oh, so viele Rs kann man nicht machen.
Okay, ich darf maximal so viele Rs machen.
Mehr Rs kann mein Reboot-Command nicht.
Guck mal.
Ich kann maximal so viele Rs.
Warum kann ich nicht mehr Rs?
Ah, weil ich nur 1 bis 200 Rs supporte.
Also Maximum
Erstmal Reboot in
Okay, da kann ich auch mit leben
200 R sind okay
Bam
Mal Tastatur umstöpseln
Ja, please.
Booten.
Wie das funktioniert?
Blazingly Fast, written in Rust.
Muss dein Chat sein.
Ne, Blazingly Fast, wie gesagt, Blazingly Fast ist nicht mal angesagt.
Laser Speed sagt man dazu mittlerweile.
Laser Speed Fast.
Also wenn dein Chat nicht in drei Mikrosekunden respondet, geht das nicht.
wird so timeoutet direkt ins band timeout größer kleiner kleiner gleich ich
bin ich bin fair ich bin fair kleiner gleich drei mikrosekunden
max sagt mir warum ist das mittlerweile so schwer eine app im playzone weil
apple den arsch offen hat
Ah ne, Playstore ist Android
Ähm
Keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen
Ich hab noch nie ne App veröffentlicht im Playstore
Okay, ich hab auch noch nie ne App im Appstore veröffentlicht
Aber ich kenne Leidensgeschichten über Appveröffentlichungen im Appstore, ja
Und wisst ihr, was
besonders sagt? Ach, es geht um
einen Gameboy-Emulator, verstehe ich mal, gell?
Denke ich mal.
Apple,
ähm, nee, Android macht es einem ja mittlerweile
auch mit Sideloaden immer schwieriger, ne?
Na, bei Apple hast du das Problem
Du musst, also das erste Problem bei Apple
Was heißt Problem?
Das erste Ding beim Apple Ökosystem ist
Wenn du Apps veröffentlichen willst
Oder wenn du Apps entwickeln möchtest
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz andere Musik anmachen
Mal noch irgendwas
Alter, warum kackt das ab?
Das geht weg
Nein, das braucht...
Das kommt jetzt nicht.
Irgendwas Entspanntes?
Die Mario Kart Musik hatten wir schon so oft.
Das ist doch immer nett.
Das ist immer nett.
Ne, Moment, das hatten wir.
Wir hatten noch hier cheerful, happy and cheerful
Nintendo Music. Das ist immer nett.
Nette Playlist.
Müssen wir noch warten,
bis der YouTube
Player sich eingekriegt hat.
Also, genau, jetzt wolltest du jetzt erzählen,
zu Apple. Also, das erste ist
beim Apple Ökosystem,
du brauchst ein Mac, um Mac-Anwendungen
zu erstellen. So. Um
iOS-Anwendungen zu erstellen.
Das ist schon mal das erste.
Kannst nicht einfach was erstellen. Das zweite ist,
selbst wenn du es könntest,
dann kannst du es nur über den Play Store
machen, weil Sideloaden auf Apple
Geräten geht nicht. Sternchen,
ich weiß, dass es geht, aber die Apps
löschen sich nach kurzer Zeit wieder von alleine.
Also auch nicht zu gebrauchen.
Das heißt, du brauchst einen Mac und du musst über den App Store gehen.
Oder du brauchst irgendeinen Online-Service, der das signen kann für dich.
Aber keine Ahnung, wie das genau funktioniert.
Zumindest musst du extra Geld ausgeben.
Und du brauchst einen Apple-Developer-Account, wo du Geld bezahlen musst für ein Code-Signing-Zertifikat.
Ohne dass Apple dich nichts veröffentlichen lässt.
Also die Hürden sind da relativ hoch.
hat aber auch
einen Vorteil,
könnte man zumindest so sehen,
weil
es kann halt nicht jeder Depp und Scammer
hingehen
und irgendwas veröffentlichen.
Direkt. Also
das kann man jetzt so und so sehen.
Aber es ist zumindest gar nicht so einfach, irgendwas
für iOS zu veröffentlichen.
Lofus, danke schön für den Sub.
Und auch der Schnuller. Moin. Schön, dass du am Start bist, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Diese Playlist verstehe ich nicht. Diese Playlist hört sich immer ein bisschen lauter an als die anderen.
Aber wenn ich dann gucke, hier im OBS, wie laut es eigentlich ist, dann sind die anderen teilweise sogar lauter.
Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß es nicht.
Ach ja.
Und ein anderer Nachteil vom Apple Ökosystem, früher zumindest, war Objective-C.
Das ist ja besser geworden.
Ich glaube, Objective-C brauchst du heute für 99% der Sachen nicht mehr.
Das ist aber wirklich Hörensagen.
Ich habe von iOS-Entwicklung bzw. generell Mac-Entwicklung überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Aber ich glaube, Objective-C brauchst du mittlerweile wirklich 99%.
Kannst du alles mit Zwift machen.
Ist das so?
Hat jemand Ahnung von euch, was Apple-Entwicklung angeht?
Also ich glaube, das Allermeiste.
Du brauchst für ein paar ganz abgedrehte Dinger und Low-Level-Sachen, kann das sein?
Ich habe letztens, glaube ich, bei Hacker-News irgendwo gelesen, brauchst du noch Objective-C?
Oder auf Reddit irgendwo habe ich das gelesen.
Aber für 99% kommst du wohl mit Zwift mittlerweile aus.
So, jetzt sehen wir mal unsere Zerdienungskiste.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich rebooted? Ja, ich habe rebooted.
Excellent.
Rebooted.
Was ist denn FileLight?
Disk Usage Statistics.
Aha.
Homefolder.
Soll ich euch mal sagen,
das sieht gar nicht so unpraktisch aus.
Da kann man jetzt sagen,
hier, das ist fett.
Hä?
Chat, warum ist denn exakt das gleiche?
Guck mal.
Das eine ist Toolbox Apps
und das andere ist Toolbox.
Achso, achso ist das aufgeschlüsselt
Das ist dann die aufsteigenden Verzeichnisse
Das ist CacheOS, ja
Da passt, da ist der Name Programm
40 Gig Cache
Warum hab ich denn, aber, das ist aber wirklich krass
Was ist denn da alles drin, ne
Ah
Da machen wir doch mal
Machen wir doch mal NC-DU-Cache
Guck mal, was da drin ist.
Guck mal. JetBrains.
Die ganzen Toolbox-Apps.
Und yay.
Yay. Jay. Wie auch immer.
Wir können, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
das sollten wir vielleicht mal tatsächlich machen.
Wir können einfach hier hingehen und sagen,
dass der die alten
Apps löschen soll.
Das ging doch hier irgendwie.
Update.
Irgendwo
konnte man sagen, löscht die alten Dinger.
Ja, hier, guck mal.
Cleanup Previous Versions.
Cleanup Download Cache.
Cleanup Cache Frontends of Remote Tools.
Okay, bam, weg.
Alles weg.
Cleanup Leftover Directory.
Delete, delete.
Bam, siehste?
Und schon haben wir wieder ordentlich.
Und wir machen Keep Previous Versions aus,
dass wir in Zukunft ein bisschen mehr Platz sparen.
Aber ich muss ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel Platz sparen, weil...
Steht das bei NeoFetch, wie groß die Platte ist, die man hat?
Disk, genau.
Hier, Gig... ähm... Terabyte.
Terabyte SSD habe ich hier.
Ich habe sogar noch eine zweite drin.
Guck, ich habe eine NVMe 0 und eine NVMe 1.
und ich könnte theoretisch sogar
Guck mal, das sind zwei
zweimal eine 1TB Platte.
Ich könnte theoretisch sogar noch die zweite SSD
dafür benutzen.
Wobei ich das ja eigentlich
will ich das nicht,
weil ich mach das ja zur Zeit so,
auf der SSD ist das Betriebssystem drauf
zum Streamen und auf dieser
SSD ist das Betriebssystem drauf, wo ich
halt privat bastle
auf dem mini pc beides hier so eingerichtet mit verschlüsselung und
allem das ich nicht aus versehen von einem auf das andere zugreife
ja so sieht's aus und wie jetzt kann man jetzt kann man das updaten das müsste
cash weg sein okay okay das tool finde ich gar nicht schlecht wobei ich wobei
ich habe euch ehrlich sagen muss ich bin immer noch der meinung dass ncd ist halt beste das
gibt es in jedem standard repo auf jedem server können das installieren kann ich euch beide way
nur empfehlen wenn ihr öfters remote auf servern seit und da ab und zu mal was aufräumen müsst
und gucken müsst wo ist besonders viel drin und so finde ich das viel angenehmer als rein mit die
rum zu krebsen ja weil man kann ja man kann hier beispielsweise auch rein tappen und gucken wo ist
hier viel zeug belegt also werden pass auf administrieren muss nc du kann ich kann ich
nur empfehlen und wisst ihr wisst ihr was für mich wirklich hart ob zum absolut gottet so prozess und
was geht auf meinem rechner ab monitoring machen würde so zum live view wenn die es noch schaffen
würden, einen Network-Tab hier oben
einzuführen. Wäre das nicht geil,
Leute? Guck mal, H-Top kann
mittlerweile ziemlich gut
Prozesse
und I.O.
Ist der nicht schon angekündigt? Ne, habe ich
nichts gesehen. Wenn die jetzt noch
wenn die jetzt noch auf Prozess
Prozess-basiert Netzwerk
Auslastung hätten. Also was H-Top
kann ist, H-Top kann irgendwie
hier oben oder so die Netzwerk-Auslastung
anzeigen von insgesamt.
Aber ich will eine Netzwerkauslastung von Prozessen.
Das wäre so geil, wenn H-Top das könnte.
Also ich meine, nur mit Sudo, okay, aber das wäre ja in Ordnung.
Kann das B-Top? Ne, B-Top kann das auch nicht.
Also das einzige Tool, was mir einfällt, was ich auch öfters benutze, was das kann, ist NetHox.
Ja, also NetHox kann das, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das installiert habe.
ich weiß nicht ob es irgendwie so ein anderes standard tool gibt was in allen
distros drin ist
nettox musste mit sudo starten und wenn du jetzt hier zeug machst dann siehst du
warum steht man firefox jetzt eigentlich beide way nach doch hier firefox guckt
du siehst immer so ein fünf sekunden window oder so wie schnell hier die
die einzelnen Prozesse. Aber du siehst es halt bei NetHox,
ist halt das Coole, du siehst das auf
Prozessebene.
Ja, das ist ganz nice.
Es gibt übrigens noch ein anderes Ding.
Gegenstück. Geil.
Ich kann das nicht mal beenden mehr.
Es ist broken. Doch jetzt.
Es gibt noch Bandwitch
oder so.
Witch.
Nee, nicht Hexe.
Bandwitch gibt es noch.
Das ist quasi NetHox.
Das ist NetHox written in Rust.
Okay.
Guck mal, da macht es sogar Namensauflösung.
Ludl.
Was ist denn mcast.net eigentlich?
Achso, Multicast.
Haben wir bestimmt Minus-Minus, wenn wir keine...
Ja.
Ja, kann man sagen, weil er ist ja schneller, wenn er keine Namensauflösung macht.
Also das ist auch noch ganz okay, wenn man sich das anschauen will.
Aber NetHox ist halt auf allen Distributionen mit dabei, wenn man das braucht.
Sieht komplett Hackermans aus.
Also die beste Hackermans-Geschichte ist immer noch,
warte mal, Docker run
machen wir diesen Krempel hier mal weg
Ubuntu latest, holen wir uns mal einen Docker Container
Ist WSL nicht
in sich gekapselt, was Netzwerk
betrifft oder sieht das auch das Zeugs von Windows?
Das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung, ich habe
WSL nicht installiert
Das müsste einer von euch noch gucken
Kein Schimmer, ob das so ist.
Du hast gerade bei ChatGPT eine Anzeige bekommen.
Wie?
Was soll das heißen? Werbung oder wie?
Bei ChatGPT, tatsächlich.
Interesting.
Also Leute, das beste Hackertool ist immer noch das hier.
Wenn euer Chef reinkommt und ihr wollt furchtbar...
Äh, keine Ahnung, ist mir jetzt vollkommen egal.
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Wo ist dein German?
46, okay.
Eins.
Ja, irgendwas ist mir doch egal, Alter.
Arabik, Afrika.
Das brauch ich eh nicht.
Und was für ein Ad hast du bekommen?
So, wir inszenieren jetzt mal kurz das halbe Internet nach, ne?
Beim 8-Euro-Abo gibt's jetzt Werbung.
Aha.
Okay.
Moment.
Es gibt jetzt mit Abo Werbung.
Ja gut, ja.
So, aber das beste Hackertool ist immer noch das hier.
Wenn euer Chef reinkommt und ihr wollt einfach wahnsinnig beschäftigt aussehen, Leute, dann Hollywood öffnen.
Easy.
Und dann am besten Pace Rollen über die Tastatur noch.
So hier.
Müsst ihr dann da sitzen.
Moment.
Chef, ich hab's gleich.
Oh Mist, ich hab's glaube ich kaputt gemacht gerade.
Kann auch was zu trinken einschenken
Also das ist echt beste Hacker-Man-Ansicht
Boah, vor allem das C-Matrix
Ich glaube, ich habe das gerade ziemlich zerstört
Dadurch, dass ich
so wie verrückt auf der Tastatur rumgehauen hab.
Ist es bei euch übrigens auch so, dass
der Encoder, der Video-Encoder
das Bild total verpixeln lässt,
wenn ich so viel Terminal Operations
mache, mache, mache hier.
Also pixelt bei euch der Stream jetzt,
wenn das Terminal so am Ausrasten ist?
Also bei mir in der Vorschau
pixelt es ein bisschen.
Ne? Okay, Chat.
Wenn das nicht reicht,
das hier, aber das, das, das
pixelt jetzt wenigstens gleich, oder? Hoffe ich mal.
Sag bloß, das pixelt auch nicht.
Das pixelt auch nicht.
Alter, die haben ihren Encoder verbessert.
OBS hat
wohl Encoding-Settings
standardmäßig geändert, würde ich sagen.
Weil früher hat C-Matrix im Fullscreen immer dicker gepixelt.
Ich habe eigentlich an den Encoder-Settings nichts geändert.
Aber vielleicht ist es ja OBS-Default, was sich ein bisschen geändert hat.
Tja.
Siehst du mal.
Pixel-Free C-Matrix.
Weil ich war heute...
Ich war heute beim Barbershop.
Der hat 45 Minuten an mir rumgebabershoppt
Und hat mich danach
Übelst zugeschüttet
Mit so
Weiß ich, keine Ahnung was das ist
So
Profimkram, ja
Mein ganzes Zimmer riecht nach Friseur
Hier jetzt, mein ganzes Arbeitszimmer
Selbst wenn ich rausgehe
Die Treppe runter
Und komm dann wieder hoch
Das ganze Zimmer, das riecht wirklich wie
wie im Friseurladen jetzt.
Aber der hat super krass draufgehauen.
Normalerweise
hauen die einfach
nur ein bisschen hier so
drauf, da wo sie den Bart geschnitten haben
mit dem Messer. Und danach machen sie so
Creme drauf und gut ist. Der Typ heute
hat, ohne Scheiß, der hat
irgendwie achtmal gesprayt
und danach von dieser Creme
hat er mir am Bart gemacht, an den Backen gemacht
und sogar auf den Kopf gemacht.
Er hat komplett
alles eingeschmiert.
Und, ey, das ist wirklich hart.
Ich muss heute Abend unbedingt lüften, wenn das ein bisschen sich verdünnt hat.
Dachte, du gehst zum...
Der heißt doch gar nicht mehr so.
Der heißt doch jetzt Fab oder so.
Ne, ich hab vor dem Friseur geduscht
Da wollte ich jetzt nicht direkt
Nach dem Friseur nochmal haben
Kannst ja auch übertreiben
So, haben wir schon geab...
Ja, wir haben schon geupdatet
Leute, guckt euch mal an
Wir haben geupdatet und jetzt gibt es schon wieder
Das nächste Update
Arsch, by the way.
Ach nee, das ist NetHox, weil ich es aus dem falschen Repo
installiert habe. Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Du hast beim Fabian
unsubbed. Warum?
Was hat er denn hochgeladen?
Der hat doch, hat er noch was hochgeladen?
Der hat das Black Ops 7 Video hochgeladen.
Hat er danach noch was hochgeladen?
Der Osten meldet sich zurück.
Okay.
Doch, keine Ahnung.
So.
Du bist wahrscheinlich kein zwölfjähriges Call of Duty Kind mehr.
Wie früher.
So wie viele.
Und ich auch nicht mehr.
Oder wir auch nicht mehr.
Da gibt es Sachen, die man damals cool fand,
die gefallen einem halt nicht mehr.
Geht mir auch bei einigen Sachen auf YouTube so.
Wobei YouTube Deutschland ist ja prinzipiell
übelst cringe.
Da gucke ich mir ja gar nichts an.
Oh, mit 18, da warst du tatsächlich schon einer der Älteren damals.
Die meisten Leute, die
damals zugeschaut haben, keine Ahnung,
waren irgendwie 12, 13, 14 oder so
und haben im
Xbox Live
Sprachnachrichten-Chat da rumgeflamed.
Alter, du Hünsen, deine Mutter!
Also Xbox Live-Messages waren beste damals.
Ich hab die alle aufgehoben.
Die hab ich heute noch.
Sofern Microsoft den Kram nicht gelöscht hat.
Die ganzen Messages von damals,
wo die Leute rumgeflamed haben.
Was soll ich denn sagen mit 42, Mann?
Ich bin ja noch älter.
Ich komm mir teilweise auch alt vor mit 42, ne?
Ob ich der Einzige bin, der 42 ist und keck weh sagt?
Ohne das lustig, also ohne das, ohne das, ähm...
Wie kann man sagen?
Also es gibt Leute, die sagen das, um die Leute, die sowas sagen, zu verarschen, ja?
Die sagen dann, haha, keck weh oder so, um die Leute zu verarschen, die sowas benutzen, ja?
Aber ich sag das quasi ernst.
Warum ist das ein Rust-Repo?
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Weg damit.
Soll hier überhaupt kein Rust-Repo sein?
Okay, wie nennen wir unser Programm?
Das wird der, äh, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Rust-Bastel-Champ, okay?
Wenn ich noch nicht genau weiß, was wir da zustande bringen.
Gut, ähm, so, hier haben wir den Kram.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich alles erledigt habe.
Oder ob ich auch irgendwie vorher was machen muss.
Nö, ich glaub nicht.
Okay.
Achso doch siehste
Ich hab nicht aufgepasst
Ich muss das nochmal löschen
Und zwar ich will ja
Ein Projekt klonen
Und zwar ein Rust Projekt
Und das ganze soll
Rust Bastl Champ heißen
Okay
Jetzt haben wir es
Exzellent
Okay
Dann connecten wir uns mal in den Container rein
Hast du eigentlich schon Erfahrung mit OpenClaw?
Nö
Das dauert jetzt kurz
Der muss jetzt erstmal den Dev-Container basteln
Muss der einmalig machen bei jedem neuen Projekt
Ist trotzdem besser
Da mal 5 Minuten zu warten
Wenn man ein neues Projekt startet
Dafür ist man nicht mehr so anfällig
was Supply Chain Angriffe angeht.
Dacht der OpenClaw ist tot.
Ist es das? Ist nicht der
OpenClaw Entwickler quasi
mit OpenClaw irgendwie zu OpenAI
gewechselt und
wollte das irgendwie weiterentwickeln?
Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich verfolge das nicht so richtig.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
mir geht es auch ein bisschen
am Arsch vorbei,
was sie da so treiben.
Also wenn du, das ist ein bisschen, erinnert ihr euch noch früher an JavaScript-Entwicklung?
Es verging kein Tag, dass nicht drei neue JavaScript-Frameworks erfunden wurden.
Und wenn du heute was in JavaScript entwickelt hast, und das Projekt quasi ein halbes Jahr später wieder geöffnet hast,
waren 90% der Sachen outdated und deprecated, die du drinnen verwendet hast.
So
Und so ist das heute
Wenn du Schritt halten willst
Mit den Entwicklungen beispielsweise auf GitHub
Was KI angeht
Es gibt jeden Tag 5 neue
Agent Tools
Harness Dinger
Repo
Komprimierungssachen
Irgendwelche lokalen Models
Zum Laufen lassen
Da blickst du nicht mehr durch
Ich picke mir da nur die interessanten Sachen raus
Ich gucke dann ab und zu ein bisschen auf Hacker News
Ich gucke ein bisschen auf Reddit, gucke mir ein bisschen auf GitHub
Die Sachen an, aber da wirklich
100%ig alles verfolgen
Das ist mir auch die Zeit zu schade für
Ich denke mir immer
Wenn man sich das dann 2-3 Monate später
Anguckt, dann hat sich dann schon rauskristallisiert
Was davon was taugt, was davon einfach nur
Irgendwie sinnlos ein Tageshype
War
So, dann lassen wir uns
Die IDI öffnen
Ide
Also Leute, wir werden heute nicht
Vibe coden, das heißt aber nicht,
dass wir gar keine KI verwenden werden.
Weil um so Sachen zu
fragen wie, wie öffne ich
in Rust gescheit einen USB-Device oder so,
da werde ich Google
fragen, wenn nichts gescheites rauskommt, frage ich
die KI, das hat ja mit Vibe coden dann nichts
zu tun. Ich sage dem ja nicht, ich brauche
ein Projekt, was das, das und das macht.
Ja, also als Dagger-Overflow-Ersatz werde ich es
trotzdem verwenden.
Doch, genau genommen ist es das.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Kram noch so hieß.
Ob der noch so heißt. Ich glaube, mittlerweile
heißt es einfach nur IntelliJ.
Ups.
So.
Zack.
Rust.
So.
Jetzt ist erstmal IDE,
erstmal Container geöffnet,
jetzt ist erstmal für zwei Minuten der Rechner ausgelastet hier, Leute.
Jetzt machst du erstmal nichts mehr auf dem Rechner.
Guck, bam.
Vibecon sagt man nichts mehr.
Agentic Engineering sagt man heute,
aber das Wort ist so dumm.
Da ist mir Vibe-Coden sogar lieber.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal warten, bis Rust Rover das auf die Kette gebracht hat hier.
So, dass man es benutzen kann.
Das könnte tatsächlich ein bisschen problematisch sein, dass ich so wenig RAM habe.
Dass es langsamer ist, als es sein müsste.
Ja, ja, Argentic Engineering sagt man jetzt.
Das weiß ich aber auch nur, weil ich das letztens in einem YouTube-Video gesehen habe.
Wo das einer super ernst gesagt hat.
So nach dem Motto, ich mache jetzt hier Guide, Tutorial, da und dazu.
Und if you are an agentic engineering user oder was auch immer.
Und dann erzählt er, okay, Vibe-Coding is out, agentic engineering.
Ja, Rust, mach hinne.
Also ich bin mir ein bisschen unschlüssig, was Rust Rover und Rust da im Hintergrund gerade macht.
Aber es scheint viel CPU zu verbrauchen.
bin ich dann ein agent test automation engineer weiß ich nicht kommt drauf an was du machst du
kannst hier letztendlich für deinen job einen beliebigen titel ausdenken es juckt eh keinen
ich glaube jetzt ich glaube es ist fertig glaube jetzt hat es gecheckt
Das war jetzt sehr schlau, Max
Jetzt habe ich das
Jetzt habe ich die IDE geöffnet, aber
Aber die SSH-Verbindung
Ah, ne, da ist es doch, hier
SSH-Verbindung wieder zugemacht
Okay, zack, auf geht's
Bam, Source
Main-RS
Dieses komische Gedöns hier ausblenden
Das hier ein bisschen
größer machen
Moment.
Hallo? Alter, IDE!
Mach hinne!
Was macht das Ding denn jetzt nach drei Stunden?
Ich will den Text größer machen.
Font Size.
Okay, perfekt.
So.
Und das muss man immer einmalig enablen,
wenn man das neu macht.
Change Font Size with
mit dem Wheel.
Chat, ich frage mich gerade, ob ich der Einzige bin,
der das hat.
Guck mal, ich brauche diese Seitenbar
hier eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Ja, ich mache das alles
meistens hier über die Pfeilsuche und sowas,
wenn ich Dateien öffnen will.
Ich klicke eigentlich
sehr selten hier in dieser Sidebar, aber
nichtsdestotrotz, ich kann es
nicht haben, wenn die Sidebar
zu ist. Ich brauche die
Sidebar nicht, aber ich mag es nicht, wenn sie
zu ist. Ich habe immer
die Sidebar auf, ohne dass ich sie benutze.
Geht es noch irgendjemanden so?
Ich kriege das...
By the way, warum habe ich das eigentlich da drin?
Das sollte besser hier in Main.
Okay, jetzt
tracen wir mal irgendwas.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Run.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze läuft.
Das sollte jetzt eigentlich nur Info rausschreiben und sonst nichts.
Aber Rust kompiliert am Anfang
eh erstmal immer das halbe Internet. Das ist normal.
Okay.
So, wir haben ganz viele Warnings, weil wir
unused dependencies haben.
Juckt mich jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt nicht.
Aber hier, Info kommt raus.
Können jetzt da nochmal hier
in den Cargo run.
Zack, Funst.
Okay. Gut.
Also, dann.
Bei der Gelegenheit,
was ich mich schon die ganze bevor wir jetzt usb geräte öffnen und so und uns
das mal angucken was ich mich schon die ganze zeit frage
kann man irgendwie beides bei der debug ausgabe hier sind nicht die bag
ausgabe bei der bei der logging ausgabe machen wir machen wir hier unten mal
irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr Ausgabe, okay?
Machen wir mal hier irgendwie, ja.
Tracing.
Trace.
Error.
Tackle.
Tracing.
Warning.
Inne 2. So ist scheißegal.
Machen wir mal ein bisschen Log-Ausgaben, okay?
Okay, standardmäßig ist Tracing nicht dabei.
Und Debug.
Müssen wir auch nochmal machen.
Debug ist standardmäßig
auch nicht dabei, oder?
Ne.
Ah, das ist nicht dabei, weil ich hier
einen Filter drauf habe. Das alles unter
Info-Level. So, was ich mich jetzt
frage ist, kann ich? Weil das
fände ich echt praktisch.
Was für ein Ding?
Ich würde einfach sagen, Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt.
Aber was ist das?
Moment.
Der Gültigkeitsbereich Operator
Der Skript Sprache PHP
Wird aus historischen Gründen auch
Pamaim
Nekudotayim
Alter was
Zwei hintereinander gestellten Doppelpunkten
Warum kann man nicht einfach sagen Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt
Doppelter Doppelpunkt
Meinetwegen
php
ups
das war mir neu, dass das in php so heißt
so, aber was ich mich jetzt eigentlich
was ich mal ausprägen will, guck mal
wir geben jetzt hier Log-Meldung aus
Also sagen wir mal
Ich will einfach alles ausgeben, okay
So, jetzt gibt er
Jetzt gibt er Info, Trace, Debug, Error
Und Warning aus
Kann man denn da jetzt irgendwie
Auch noch dazu
Allerdings bitte schon nur für Trace und Debug
Ausgaben vielleicht
Kann man da auch noch ausgeben
Wo das auftritt oder sowas
Was haben wir denn hier, Width
Was gibt es denn da noch alles
Ansi
Das sind Farben wahrscheinlich
Level.
Moment, was macht denn With Level?
Achso.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte den Filter gar nicht, oder was?
Ach, hier, guck mal.
Line Numbers.
Das war schon mal ganz praktisch.
Ja.
Ja, aber Line Numbers alleine sind jetzt auch nicht so geil, oder?
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Thread IDs, Thread Names,
Timer,
Current Subscriber,
Filter, Filter Maps, Date,
Subscriber. Ja, gibt es da nicht so was
wie noch... Ach, hier steht auch File.
Da haben wir es doch.
Ja, das ist doch schon mal deutlich praktischer.
dann erkennt man
übrigens was. So, und jetzt, und jetzt ist
die große Preisfrage.
Kann man das Logging so einstellen,
dass der
nur
für Trace und
Debug das hier anzeigt?
Oder ne, noch besser.
Noch besser.
Nur wenn das eine
Debug, nur wenn
das ein Debug-Bild ist, soll er das anzeigen.
Boah, wie macht man
sowas in Rust?
Ich bin nicht der allergrößte Rust-Profi.
Gibt es in Rust sowas?
Also in C-Sharp würde ich sowas hier machen.
If Debug.
Und if irgendwie so, glaube ich.
Irgendwie so kann man in C-Sharp machen.
Aber das ist doch was, was mit Vibe-Coding nichts zu tun hat.
Wie kann ich in Rust checken, ob Debug oder Release Build?
Wisst ihr denn?
Game Boy Pro... Pro... Progers...
Programments. Gibt es nicht sowas wie
Debugger is attached? Ja, sowas suche ich ja auch.
Hier, guck mal. CFG
Debug Assertion.
In Rust kannst du das über Debug Assertion
gucken. Guck mal, man kann...
Kann man damit...
Jetzt, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal,
warte mal, warte mal, mal ne andere, mal ne andere Sache.
Kann man damit auch irgendwie sowas machen?
So?
Irgendwie?
Ohne, dass ich die Syntax wüsste?
Okay, nee, das ist dumm.
Das hier finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Ist Debug.
So, ist Debug.
Dann sagen wir einfach hier
with target fall
line number true nur im Debug
file auch nur im Debug.
Das ist doch schon mal gut. Guck mal, jetzt haben wir das.
Wenn wir das nämlich jetzt mit Release starten
und erstmal das halbe Internet wieder neu
kompilieren.
Also erstmal das halbe Internet
runterladen und das halbe Internet kompilieren.
dann sehen wir hoffentlich, dass es jetzt
keine Zeilennummern mehr hat.
Rust ist eh immer
super krass dependency hell.
Die Standard Library ist
bei Rust sehr minimalistisch.
Aber immerhin durchdacht
minimalistisch. Nicht so ein Kack wie
in C++.
Ich sag nur Vector
auf Buhl.
Wer weiß, der weiß.
Frage in Chat.
Wer weiß denn?
Vektor auf Buhl in C++.
Wer weiß es von euch, Chat?
Vektor auf Buhl
ist nämlich in C++ gar kein Vektor
auf Buhl.
Das ist Debate.
C++
Vektor Buhl.
Weil Standard Vector Bool ist weird.
Also wer Sachen lesen möchte über Abartigkeiten von C++,
guckt euch einfach mal an, was hinter Vector auf Bool steckt.
Moin, X-Factal, moin, lange nicht gesehen.
Danke für die Subscription.
Was ich wieder mache,
ich versuche ein USB-Gerät auszulesen mit Rust.
Aber vorher bin ich gerade am überlegen,
wie ich mein Logging so einstellen kann,
dass nur wenn er im Debug-Modus ist,
er das hier macht.
Wobei das doch schon mal okay ist.
So, und jetzt kommt das Nächste.
Jetzt kommt das Nächste.
Wenn Debug ist,
dann will ich hier was anderes setzen.
Also ich will sowas machen, Chat.
Ist Debug?
Ich weiß, dass das so nicht geht, okay?
Ja?
Ist Debug?
Ansonsten ist Release.
So.
Sowas will ich jetzt machen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das in Rust macht.
Aber das kriegen wir schon raus.
Ich meine, die einfachste Variante wäre wahrscheinlich...
Okay, ich weiß was wir machen. Das ist eigentlich super easy.
Guck mal, wir sagen einfach, ist Debug. Man kann auch bestimmt hier irgendeine Function
übergeben oder sowas. Also dass man hier irgendwie sagt, so x...
Okay, das geht schon mal nicht.
Okay
Aber eins
Okay, wir können jetzt mal
Werbung für Rust machen
Rusts
Rust sind
Die
Die Endfilter klingt schon mal gut
Rust sind die Docs eigentlich
Ganz gut immer
Also wir gucken jetzt
Hier einfach mal
Oben ein if und dann in die lokale Variable
Ja, hab ich doch hier
Ach, so meinst du das
Du meinst, dass wir quasi sowas hier machen
Ah ja, ja, ja, ja, du hast recht
Du hast recht
Wir machen jetzt, genau, ja, ja, stimmt, du hast recht
Wir machen jetzt sowas wie level gleich
Und jetzt kommt, pass auf Leute, jetzt kommt
Jetzt kommt Rust Magic
Wir machen jetzt nicht if ist Debug
Wir machen jetzt match
ist Debug.
Okay, bam.
Das ist jetzt hier
richtige Rust-Hackerman-Stells.
So.
Wenn es true ist,
dann...
Nee, wenn es nicht true ist.
Dann so, ansonsten so.
Also wenn es Debug ist,
dann will ich Level-Tracing
haben.
ist eigentlich... Und ansonsten
das. Und dann machen wir hier Levelfilter.
Zack. Eats.
Da müssen wir gar nicht großartig rummachen.
So, und jetzt haben wir, wenn wir
Release haben, das so. Und wenn wir
Debug haben, haben wir diesen ganzen Mist dabei.
Das ist doch schick, oder?
Und es
gab, glaube ich, auch noch irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
dass man das noch ein bisschen schöner darstellt.
Dass man sagen kann...
Ich glaube,
Compact Falls oder
so ist das, glaube ich.
Nee.
Jason?
Pretty ist es, glaube ich.
Ja, guck.
Das ist doch schick.
Ja, Moment. Ganz ohne
Vibe-Coding heißt nicht ganz ohne KI.
Ganz ohne Vibe-Coding
heißt, hallo, liebe KI, mach mir
das und das und das. So nach dem Motto,
die KI fragen, wie kann ich in Rust
checken, ob es Debug oder Resbuild ist? Das ist ja
okay. Deswegen habe ich ja auch nicht
ohne KI geschrieben, sondern ganz
ohne Vibe-Coding.
Guck mal, das ist doch nice.
Das kann man jetzt richtig gut lesen. Und wenn es jetzt
Release ist... Achso, dann sieht
das immer noch so kacke aus.
Wie setze ich denn Pretty
jetzt nur...
Wie setze ich Pretty nur, wenn es
Debug ist?
Äh.
Gibt es sowas wie With Pretty oder so?
Format oder so?
Das geht mit Features.
Okay, erzähl mir mehr.
Format irgendwas?
Format Fields Map Event Format.
Hm.
Ich mein, das einfachste wär, ja, wir machen hier nen If.
Aber das ist doch eklig, oder?
In der Tommel kannst du Features angeben.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Und dann?
Features für was?
Für...
Für Tracing Subscriber.
Ja, aber welches denn?
Default?
N-Filter haben wir?
Matches?
Okay, dann gucken wir mal.
Rust.
Die meisten Sachen haben ganz gute Dokumentation.
Schauen wir mal.
Enables APIs that depend on the Rust Standard Library.
Depend on liballoc.
Okay, was haben wir?
Event Filter.
Enables the event filter type.
Ah, da kann man das per Environment Variablen setzen oder sowas.
Was wird gebaut?
Ich will ein USB-Gerät auslesen mit Rust.
Registry?
Ich sehe jetzt hier nichts
Wichtiges.
Hm.
Aber wie soll ich denn mit...
Ah, wie kann ich damit jetzt Pretty ein- und ausschalten?
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Was? Nein!
Required bei 9.9.
Okay, Leute, wir haben noch 2 Tage Zeit,
die Trial auszunutzen.
Lüg nicht, die Trial ist überhaupt nicht expired.
2 Tage, 2 Tage habe ich Trial noch.
Ja, wie kriege ich das jetzt hin,
dass ich Pretty dann...
Okay, okay, passt mal auf, guck mal.
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal.
Leute, ich habe eine Idee.
Pass auf, Six Head.
Wie war das so?
Muss man da eckige Klammern drumherum machen?
Das ist Rust, ne?
Wie war das nochmal?
Okay.
So, ich kann doch jetzt...
Muss man da vielleicht einen Block machen oder so?
Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Ich bin da eindeutig zu dumm dafür.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich das
Bild abhängig mache
Also ich mein, ich weiß, wie ich's machen könnte, ne
Ich könnte ein if machen
If is debug
So, das wär die einfachste
So, dann kopiere ich diese ganze Dinge hier rein und mache noch ein Else.
Aber das ist doch dumm.
Das muss doch irgendwie anders gehen.
Ich weiß, wir beschäftigen uns jetzt nicht mit dem USB-Geräte auslesen, aber ist egal.
Es geht ja auch hauptsächlich ums Rust lernen.
Und ordentliches Logging ist ja, glaube ich, für alle relevant.
Okay, wir fragen tatsächlich mal.
Ich will Pretty nur anhaben, wenn es Debug true.
Ich bin leider nirgendswo eingeloggt.
Wir müssen leider hier Crap AI verwenden.
Hä?
Okay, was ist...
Hier, Leute, ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen.
Hier.
Wir können Dings benutzen.
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
Das neue Model, wo ein bisschen gehypt war.
Das hier, gell?
Auf Reddit.
Wo die Leute ein bisschen gehypt haben.
Okay, mal gucken, was das China-Chinesen-Model sagt.
Terry, du bist zu advanceder Rust-Hacker-Man für mich.
Was?
WTF, was ist das für eine krasse Sonntags, Alter?
What?
Das check ich nicht.
Das geht mit einem If-Else-Ausdruck.
Ja.
Achso.
Ach, einfach so dann, oder wie?
Okay, das macht auch Sinn.
Also, du meinst, im Endeffekt...
Also, wenn ich das richtig sehe...
Man kann sowas hier setzen, okay?
Also im Prinzip kann man sowas hier setzen dann. Nehmen wir mal das da. Okay. So. Und da kann man dann einen Block drunter machen. Richtig? Und der wird nur ausgeführt, wenn es Debug ist.
Aber das Ding ist halt
Ich hätte das gerne
Hier drinnen
Und das funzt nicht
Dann finde ich
Das was das hier vorschlägt
Finde ich gar nicht mal
Finde ich gar nicht mal so dumm ehrlich gesagt
Das ist gar nicht mal so dumm
Guck mal das ist doch genau
Das was wir haben wollen
Hier krabbelt eine Mücke
Geh weg
Das ist doch gar nicht mal so dumm
Level ist Debug
Dann machen wir das so
Filter with Level
Und ansonsten, wenn es Debug ist
By the way, das ist auch nicht schön
Okay, also
Moment, Moment, was sagst du?
Es interessiert mich, wie das funktioniert
Du kannst bei der With-Methode
Einfach eine geschweifte Klammer setzen
Also
Also ich
Ach so meinst du
Du meinst quasi so
Und das Inet dann weglassen
Und jetzt T.Pretty
Nee? Hä?
Äh.
Ey Leute, ich bin da zu dumm für.
Ich mach das jetzt tatsächlich so.
Ich finde, das sieht tatsächlich ganz sinnig aus.
Guck mal.
Da wäre ich über kurz oder lang
Wahrscheinlich auch bei sowas rausgekommen
Was macht denn boxed
Erases the type of this layer
Return a boxed
Dünnlayer trade object
What
Das brauchen wir nicht
Das muss nicht boxed sein
Boxed is overrated
She baited
Aber sag mal, wäre es nicht sinnvoller,
wenn ich einfach sagen würde,
if, weil die KI das da so komisch schreibt,
ist lieber und dann einfach so.
Hä?
Warum gibt es das nicht?
Jetzt checke ich es in der Chat.
Warum zu...
Hä?
Warum gibt es hier eine Methode?
Pretty?
Und bei dem If gibt es das nicht?
Rust.
Ah.
Das gibt...
Hä?
Ich glaube, mein Auto-Complete ist einfach nur Kacke.
Mein Auto-Complete spackt rum.
Hä?
What the fuck?
Ich blick da mal durch.
Was ist da los?
Ich will doch einfach nur eine Logging-Ausgabe haben.
Bitte, bleib.
Was will er denn überhaupt?
Achso, ich hab hier in der Tommel
irgendeinen Mist eingetragen, ne?
Naja, ich hab hier noch ein leeres
Feature, das wollen wir natürlich nicht
Okay, dann hätte
das wahrscheinlich funktioniert, was ich hier gebaut hab
Jetzt macht er gar nichts mehr
Ist auch nice.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt ist es ganz kaputt.
Ach nee.
Method not found.
Ich check das nicht.
Hier gibt es pretty drin.
Guck mal.
Wie kann es sein, dass es hier pretty gibt?
Aber wenn ich das hinzufüge
Dann gibt es das nicht mehr
Liegt es vielleicht an dem letzten
Ah
Das
With Filter schließt das ganze ab
Okay
Boah das ist aber
Ist Debug
FMT Layer
Pretty
Okay, zack
So
FMT Layer Punkt
With Level
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder
Ah, Rust
Rust
Es geht schon wieder gut los
Okay, das finde ich immer geil.
In Rust sind teilweise einfachsten Sachen
übelst kompliziert, Alter.
Okay, ich mache das wieder rückgängig.
So, okay, wir machen jetzt
Chat-Driven
Design machen wir jetzt.
Okay, so müsste es also gehen.
Alles klar.
Nee, pretty consumed self.
Oder?
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Also, so müsste es gehen.
sagst du. With, und dann sagst du
hier, with Ansi, bla bla
bla.
Und dann...
Hä? Nee, das kann...
Ey Leute,
es kann halt sein, dass ich das nicht auf die
Reihe kriege. Ich check nicht, was
das jetzt... Aber du kannst
hier doch gar keine Variable drin machen.
Ach so, du willst
das returnen da drin.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Jetzt habe ich das verstanden, was du machen willst.
Du willst quasi hier einen Block machen.
Ja, aber das kann doch nicht sein,
dass man das so abartig schreiben muss.
Gibt es denn jetzt hier T?
Pretty? Ne, gibt es nicht.
Okay.
Wisst ihr was? Scheiß drauf.
Moment, jetzt gibt da gar nichts mehr aus.
Äh.
Warum gibt der jetzt gar nichts mehr aus?
Was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht?
Chat, jetzt geht es
gar nicht mehr. Es ist komplett kaputt.
Scheiße.
Ach, ich habe Init vergessen. Init fehlt.
Init. Okay.
Init hat gefehlt. Das war es.
Okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Okay, also so wirklich schlau daraus geworden bin ich immer noch nicht.
Das muss doch... Ey, das ärgert mich. Das muss doch gehen.
Also Init muss weg.
With Filter muss auch weg.
So.
Ah, muss ich vielleicht?
Warum gibt es denn jetzt schon wieder kein Pretty?
Das ist ja schlimm, Alter.
Okay.
Nachdem ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf habe,
dass ich hier noch
Durchdreher an so einem Publisher locker
konfigurieren.
Ist Debug.
Ja.
Else.
So.
Fertig.
Das ist jetzt hässlich,
aber es funktioniert.
Guck, Release so.
So.
Passt.
Ja, ne, es gibt nix mit Buhlen dafür.
Ja, Rust ist teilweise schon ein wenig verwirrend.
Aber wir lassen das jetzt so.
Sonst mach ich noch drei Stunden mit diesem komischen Logger hier rum.
Pass mal auf
Wir lassen uns jetzt Jibaden
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal Jibaden von der KI
Schöner machen
Bam, guck mal was das sagt
Oh, es denkt schon mal hart
Das finde ich nicht schöner, ehrlich gesagt.
Das kompiliert noch nicht mal, was du hier machst.
Das ergibt schon mal überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das kompiliert noch nicht mal.
Ja, wir Vibe-Coden ja auch nicht.
Mit einem N-Filter.
Ah.
Bringt das wirklich was?
Geht das wirklich?
Dass man jetzt sagt, hier?
Nö.
Das ist, was die KI sich ja ausdenkt.
Moment, FMT-Layer?
Ach so, macht er hier oben.
Okay.
Level?
Ey, das ist doch nicht mal gültige...
Das ist doch nicht mal fucking gültige Syntax, was der hier raushaut.
Ich lass das jetzt.
Das ist mir zu dumm.
guck mal der ist auch der meinung das würde funktionieren aber das ist die
welt das geht nicht die sind die kris so ist das wegen weit kommen wie die kris
zu dumm dafür.
What?
Äh.
What the fuck?
Oh, die KI ist zu dumm dafür.
Die checkt es nicht.
Das Rust ist zu high IQ für die KI.
Guck. Geht nicht. Bam.
She baited.
Wir lassen es jetzt so.
Sonst dreh ich hier noch am Rad.
Aber wir haben zumindest schon mal
schöne Log-Ausgabe. Das ist doch schon mal nice.
Okay, so.
Wie öffnen wir... Ich muss jetzt erstmal
das USB-Gerät wieder anschließen.
Zack.
USB-Device
detected. Yeah!
So.
Dann beschäftigen wir uns doch jetzt mal
weiter
mit Rust Basics
erst einmal.
Wie lagere
ich das denn jetzt hier schön aus?
Kann man da so was
hier machen?
So was wie...
Ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal
helper.rs
oder so.
Und da...
Und da schieben wir das rein,
dass ich das nicht immer sehen muss.
Das wird
dann ein Function.
Config
Logging oder irgendwie sowas.
Uhrlogging.
Okay, so.
Jetzt ist das hier drin.
Und kann ich jetzt da drauf zugreifen?
Nee.
Da muss ich jetzt sagen, oben...
Ne, Mod Helper ist schon drin.
Ah, das muss public gemacht werden, gell?
Pub muss man so machen, glaube ich.
Und jetzt geht das.
Config Logging.
Okay.
Ah ja, sehr schön.
Guck mal, jetzt sieht das doch schon gleich...
Jetzt müssen wir uns dieses hässliche Ding hier wenigstens nicht jedes Mal angucken.
das heißt wenn ich release mache habe ich nur info error warning output wenn ich ein debug
bild mache habe ich das schön formatiert mit mir sogar mit mehreren zeilen so dass man es
ordentlich lesen kann wobei ich ja sagen muss so wirklich wirklich großer fan von der mehrzeiligen
ausgabe bin ich nicht weil es schlecht zu kreppen ist aber das macht in dem fall nichts aber man
Du kannst einfach immer nach Les pipen.
Und, äh...
Was sagt Cat pipen?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hä?
Moment, Leute.
Jetzt bin ich gerade super krass verwirrt.
Wenn ich es nach Les pipe,
warum kriege ich dann keine Ausgabe?
Oder sehe ich die bloß nicht?
Ich sehe die nur nicht.
Moment, ich habe Less nicht installiert.
Alter.
Das wird sein.
Deswegen geht das nicht.
Üh.
Der macht jetzt Ansi-Sequenzen und so rein.
Kann man dem auch noch sagen, dass er das ausschalten soll?
Kann man sagen, hier.
An sie?
Nur, bitte nur einschalten,
wenn es auch auf den Terminal
Output geht.
Boah, das wäre natürlich nice.
Rust, check if
Output is
Terminal.
Rust.
Is Terminal.
Also...
Jetzt...
Ist...
Terminal?
Äh...
Standard in?
I.O. Standard in?
Oder ist es SCD?
IO?
Standard.
Standard Out, ne?
Muss ich dann gucken.
Standard Out
ist Terminal.
Oh ja, das ist nice.
Guck mal, das heißt, so kriege ich jetzt Farben
und so sollte ich...
Und so kriege ich keine Farben mehr.
Ja, Minus R. Ich weiß, Minus R kann Farben darstellen.
Aber es ist glaube ich besser, weil dann ist nämlich auch wenn ich es in eine Textdatei umleite, keine Farbe drin.
Das ist viel besser.
Ja, das ist ein gutes Setting.
Let's enable color.
Das muss ich mir nochmal ein bisschen genauer angucken, wie man das hier schöner machen kann.
Ja, aber das gefällt mir.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir hier eine schöne farbige Ausgabe.
Und wenn man das weg macht, hat man das...
Ja, ja, das ist gut. Das gefällt mir.
Was macht Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt?
Doppelpunkt Doppelpunkt ist für statische Funktionen.
Also wenn ich sowas hier zum Beispiel habe, guck.
Struct.
Chatter.
und sage jetzt,
wenn ich jetzt eine Funktion
anlege für den Typ
Chatter, mit dem
Funktion Keckel anlege,
dann
ist das eine statische
Funktion. Das heißt, wenn ich die aufrufen will,
muss ich sagen, Chatter
Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, Keckel.
Wenn ich sage, Self,
dann ist es eine,
die an die jeweilige Instanz gebunden ist.
Guck, wenn ich jetzt sage Chatter
Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, dann muss ich eine gültige
Instanz übergeben. Das geht nicht.
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich sagen,
let Chatter gleich Chatter
So, muss ich das anlegen
und jetzt kann ich auf die Instanz von
Chatter das aufrufen. Also Doppelpunkt,
Doppelpunkt ist quasi für statische
statische Funktionen,
statische Methoden
aus so einem Struct
zum Aufrufen.
Und es wird benutzt
für namespaces oder module heißt es in rust glaube ich also wenn du statische funktionen
aufrufen willst heißt im endeffekt das hier ist alles namespaces gedöns namespaces gedöns und
das ist eine statische funktion können wir auch gucken ob das wirklich stimmt ja guck
PubFN Registry
Statische Funktion
Unabhängig von irgendeiner
Struct Instanz
Und Enums, ja
Richtig
So, eine halbe Stunde gebraucht, um unseren Logger
Richtig zu konfigurieren, exzellent
So muss das sein
Logchamp
Gut, jetzt lesen wir
ein USB... Ich weiß, dass
das expiert. Das nervt mich doch nicht.
So, jetzt müssen wir
gucken, wie man...
Kann ich nicht aus Helpers einfach
alles importieren?
Och, noch viel besser. Guck mal.
Muss ich nicht die einzelnen Dinger da angeben.
So.
USB-Gerät
öffnen wollen wir jetzt.
Dafür habe ich mir nämlich eine Library rausgesucht, die sich NUSBRust.
Und da gibt es glücklicherweise auch ein paar Examples dazu.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, wie man das mit Tokio macht.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich muss das nicht Async machen, wir können das auch synchron machen.
Aber das hier. Das ist doch ein ganz gutes Beispiel hier.
Also.
List devices.
Wait. Unwrap.
Find. Expect.
Okay, da denken wir uns gleich noch irgendwas schöneres aus.
Also, so öffnet man USB-Geräte.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken.
LS-USB.
Den da will ich haben.
Das hier ist die Geräte-ID und das hier ist der Hersteller.
Oder umgedreht.
Oder es könnte auch sein, dass das hier der Hersteller ist.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das hier ist der Hersteller, weil hier ist der gleich.
Das hier ist die Hersteller-ID von dem USB-Gerät.
Und das ist dann die ID.
Besser gesagt die...
Product ID.
Okay, also, dann schauen wir mal.
Wie öffnen wir ein USB-Gerät?
Machen wir diesen ganzen Krempl mal weg hier.
Zack.
N-USB.
Ja, das müssen wir erstmal hinzufügen.
Wie macht man das nochmal gescheit?
Cargo add N-USB.
Ja.
Adding Features.
Tokio und Small ist nicht dabei.
Small ist eine
Alternative zu Tokio, ne?
Tokio ist eine Async-Runtime für Rust.
Da kann man dann sowas hier machen.
So, keine Ahnung.
Get, plop, await und so kann man da machen.
Aber ich habe Tokio schon drin.
Wobei wir ehrlich gesagt überhaupt
keinen Async brauchen.
Aber egal.
Warum? Warum findet er das nicht?
Ich hab's doch gerade hinzugefügt.
Ah, jetzt finde ich das.
Okay.
Wait.
Import.
Maybe future.
Okay, whatever.
Unwrap.
Aha.
Ah ja.
Ah, stimmt.
Okay, ich erinnere mich wieder. Also passt mal auf, das ist Rust-Magic jetzt.
Mit diesem Fragezeichen.
Guck mal, man kann bei Rust sagen, also Unwrap ist eine Funktion in Rust, wenn...
Also Rust hat ja keine Exceptions.
Also das heißt, Rust hat ja keine Exceptions.
Rust hat Error-Types oder Result-Types.
Ne, wie heißt das?
Option-Types und Result-Types.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier sage, List Devices, ich warte bis das fertig ist, dann returnt das ein Result.
So, und wenn ich einfach nur sagen will, scheiß drauf, ob das ein Fehler ist, gib mir das Result, dann rufe ich Unwrap aus.
Auf Unwrap macht folgendes.
Unwrap gibt mir den Wert oder aber es panikt mit dem Error.
Und das Programm beendet sich.
Das heißt, ist Unwrap eigentlich nicht so sinnvoll.
Wenn man das robust machen will.
Genau.
Und wenn deine Funktion ein Result zurückgibt vom Typ Error,
dann kann man hier, da kann man eine Abkürzung verwenden,
da kann man hier Fragezeichen machen.
Und Fragezeichen sorgt dafür, dass wenn dieses Result hier,
einen Error enthält,
dann macht es daraus einen Return und gibt den Error
zurück. So ein bisschen
Error Handling wie in Go.
Nur, dass man da nicht das ausschreiben muss.
Man könnte das auch von Hand bauen.
Also man könnte jetzt auch hier zum Beispiel sagen
Wait. Wir versuchen
mal sowas von Hand zu bauen.
Man könnte jetzt hier quasi sagen Wait.
Und ich muss noch was anderes
einstellen. On Save.
Save Actions.
Actions on Save.
Reformat Code.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ah ja, okay.
Jetzt hat es ein bisschen gebraucht.
Also guck, jetzt kann ich sagen,
jetzt könnte ich hier sagen Match.
Match ist quasi so ein bisschen wie ein Switch.
In anderen Sprachen, ja.
So in der Richtung, ja.
So, jetzt kann ich sagen, wenn das okay ist,
also wenn es ein Value
wenn es
kein Fehler geworfen hat, ja
dann hol mir
das Wert und gib den zurück.
Wenn es ein Error geworfen hat
dann könnte ich jetzt hier
sagen, return
Error.
So, irgendwie in dem
Dreh.
Hier muss ein Komma hin.
Ach, das geht ja nicht direkt, das ist
Rust. Ich glaube, man muss so machen.
Into irgendwie.
Ich glaube, so muss man machen.
Das ist die lange Schreibweise davon.
Und das Ganze kann man abkürzen.
Das Ganze kann man abkürzen,
indem man schreibt
unwrap
ein Fragezeichen.
Also das Fragezeichen entsetzt quasi
diesen kompletten
match if
switch block, den ich gerade hatte.
Also wenn das Result hier
einen Fehler enthält, dann
nimm den Fehler und returne an der Stelle.
So, können wir weitermachen.
Jetzt suchen wir ein USB-Device.
Dieses USB-Device gibt es nicht.
Hier wird standardmäßig einfach
Bäm, eine Fehlermeldung geschmissen.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe,
ups, äh,
dann sollte der gleich sagen, hier,
could not find device oder sowas,
in der Richtung.
Nachdem er drei Stunden
wieder kompiliert hat. So, guck, Bäm,
Panic. Das ist vielleicht
ganz okay, während man entwickelt, aber
wirklich schön ist die Ausgabe natürlich nicht.
Also, ich, also, stellt euch mal vor,
ihr seid User von diesem Programm
und, oder, ihr werdet
dann User, so würde bei euch die Ausgabe
aussehen.
Im Release Mode.
So, und da kriegt man
jetzt diese Ausgabe gleich. So,
wirklich viel aus, wirklich viel kann man
damit jetzt nicht anfangen, ja.
Device should be connected, okay, okay,
das kann man sich noch, aber so wirklich schön
lesbar ist es nicht. Deswegen können wir auch
das Expect ersetzen.
7LQS.
Dankeschön für den Zap.
Deswegen können wir das auch ersetzen.
Dass er an der Stelle nicht
weitermacht, ist okay. Aber ich denke,
wir könnten an der Stelle auch ein Fragezeichen
machen, oder? Geht das nicht?
Ah.
Bei Options
geht das nicht.
und find returned
eine Option
und kein Result.
Also können wir dann aber sagen
or
okay or
können wir sagen
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen or und or else?
Device not found.
So, und jetzt können wir ein Fragezeichen machen.
Und wenn wir das jetzt richtig gemacht haben...
Oh, jetzt kriegen wir ein Warning.
Oder vielleicht sollten wir, by the way, an der Stelle einfach hier auch ein Error machen draus.
Ja, und jetzt kriegen wir ein ordentlich formatiertes Error.
Error is device not found.
Das ist natürlich schon deutlich angenehmer lesbar, als dieses andere Ding von oben.
So, und wir machen das aber im Debug-Bild.
Das heißt, bei uns sieht das gar noch
besser lesbar aus.
Mal sehen, auch genau. Guck, Main-RS,
Zeile 25, kacken wir ab.
Excellent.
Gut.
So, und jetzt öffnen wir mal den
richtigen USB-Stick. Das heißt, wir machen mal
eine Function.
Hier, wieder so.
Die muss auch überhaupt nicht
A-Swing sein. Macht dann überhaupt keinen Sinn,
dass die A-Swing ist.
So.
Function.
Ja, OpenUSB nennen wir die jetzt mal.
Hier hat ein Result.
So, dann schieben wir diesen ganzen Mist mal hier rein.
Was hat das jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ach so, ich returne kein Result.
Deswegen, das mag der nicht.
Okay.
Aber ich will ja tatsächlich diesmal einen Wert zurückgeben.
Das ist ja quasi, das ist sowas wie 0 im Endeffekt, ohne wirklich 0 zu sein.
Wieso machst du eigentlich Welt, damit blockierst du die Async-Cursor?
Das ist richtig.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf, mich jetzt auch noch mit Async-Zeug rumschlagen zu müssen.
Ich habe auch von NUSB auch gar nicht die Tokyo Feature aktiviert.
Warum machst du dann A-Sync?
Weil es in meinem Projekt Template so drin ist.
Mach Aces in die Signatur und ersetze Await mit Wait.
Du meinst, ich soll Wait mit Await ersetzen.
Das geht nicht, weil...
Await gibt es nicht an der Stelle.
Ach doch.
Okay.
Okay. Hä?
Warum geht das? Ich hab...
Leute, ich hab...
Ich hab
Feature Tokyo nicht installiert für NUSB.
Ich dachte, das geht doch nicht.
Ja, so ist auch gut.
Ne, da so ist ja noch besser.
So, open.
Was ist das?
Open USB.
Okay, so.
So, wie geht denn das hier weiter?
DeviceInfo, nennen wir das mal.
Und jetzt kann man sagen,
Open.
Device
Ne, jetzt muss ich, jetzt muss ich erst einmal,
bevor ich das hier mache,
hm, ah gut, okay,
ne, wir machen das jetzt, wir machen das trotzdem mal.
Ich returne jetzt
ein was? Ein Interface, ne?
Ein N-USB
Device.
Ne, was returnt dieses
Ding?
interface interface okay das return ein n usb interface hinter face
So
Okay
So, und das returnen wir jetzt
Dann haben wir das Gerät geöffnet
Wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar Unwraps
Oh, der Tommy ist Rust High IQ Man
Das heißt, an der Stelle können wir auch Await machen
await
und returnen,
wenn es eben einen Fehler gibt.
Und hier können wir auch sagen,
await?
Ohne das Ding.
Ah, das geht jetzt nicht.
Ah, ich muss sagen,
okay.
Jaja, da wäre ich jetzt auch selbst drauf gekommen.
Okay.
Aha
So, jetzt können wir das USB-Gerät öffnen
Das geht natürlich nicht, weil das USB-Gerät gerade nicht da ist
Aber wir müssen mal gucken, kriegen wir eine ordentliche Fehlermeldung
Error device not found
Gut, dann schauen wir uns jetzt mal an, wie das USB-Device eigentlich heißt
Also, diese zwei Dinger brauchen wir da
Wir machen doch
Dann machen wir es doch so
Guckt mal
Vendor ID
Ist es ein U16? U16
Dann machen wir nochmal hier
U16, ne das umgedreht geht das
Vendor
Und
Product
U16
Dann setzen wir hier
Vendor ein und da Product,
dass der das ordentlich filtern
kann. Und jetzt können
wir ja hier unten
sagen,
das da als Vendor
und das da als
Product.
Achso, 0x.
0x.
Also heißt
im Endeffekt jetzt,
Oh.
Ja, von wegen.
Ja, das punzt nicht. Guck mal.
Awaiting blocking syscall without an async runtime.
Man kann das nicht benutzen,
wenn man
Tokio nicht...
Okay, dann machen wir einfach Feature...
Hier, machen wir einfach add
minus minus
Feature
Tokio.
Du hattest doch Tokyo Main in der Man...
Ja, aber anscheinend braucht er auch für...
Für NUSB braucht dieses Feature aktiviert, dass es geht.
Guck jetzt, funzt.
Äh, aber er findet das Device nicht.
Ah, weil ich im Container bin.
Also, Sekunde, Leute, ich muss das nochmal neu starten.
Ich muss gerade mal in meinem Container den Kram durchschleifen.
Sekunde, ich muss gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Ich hab's mir hier irgendwo aufgeschrieben.
Ähm...
Warte mal, wo hab ich's?
So geht das.
Pass auf hier.
Trick 17.
Nachdem ich das letzte Mal so lang rumgemacht hab,
hab ich mir aufgeschrieben, wie es funktioniert.
Hier, Def-Container, JSON.
So, wir müssen jetzt hier hin.
Das können wir uns übrigens raus...
Ich copy-paste mir das.
Kann ich gescheit copy-pasten?
Von hier nach hier funktioniert...
Aber von hier nach hier funktioniert das auch, ist die Frage.
Ha! Es funzt!
Machen wir die Mounts raus.
Run Arcs. Sehr gut.
Also hier.
Device Group...
Device Group Rule C189...
Doppelpunkt Sternchen...
RMW? Fragt mich bitte nicht, aber das führt dazu, dass ich im Container mein USB-Gerät verwenden kann.
Alles klar?
Obviously, ne?
Ich hoffe, euch ist allen klar, was das hier macht.
Ich finde, das ist so offensichtlich, das muss man nicht erklären.
Ist einfach Linux-Schnitzel, fragt mich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Das ist irgendeine Regel für C-Groups
C-Groups ist ja ein Teil von Linux-Containern
Also ich kann es bis zu einem gewissen Teil
Prüfungsrelevant nicht, aber
Morgen ist Daily Scrum
Da will ich von dir die Zusammenfassung
nochmal hören, Quatschkopf
Also ein bisschen
zusammen reiben kann ich es mir ja
C-Groups ist ja ein Teil
ein Bestandteil von dem, was man unter Linux
was man unter Container
Container bestehen aus, zum größten Teil
sind es zwei Sachen, C-Groups und Namespaces
C-Groups ist für diesen Sandbox-Teil
berechnungsmäßig
zuständig und
Namespaces, dass es im Container
ein bisschen anders aussieht
als auf dem Host, dem Container ein bisschen was
vorzugaukeln, das sind die zwei Parts
und das ist irgendeine Regel, wenn
dieser Container startet, dass C-Groups
erlauben soll
auf diese Devices irgendwie
diese Rechte zu haben, keine Ahnung, frag
mich nicht
ich hoffe, dass
Ich hoffe, dass Funz jetzt ohne dass ich den Container neu starte
Ich glaube, ich muss den Container nochmal neu starten
Dass das richtig funktioniert
Rust Rover
Passendes Rusty Mode
Okay, mach ich
Während das hier
Den Container baut, mach ich, Moment
Ja, sehr schön, das machen wir
Ähm, sign in
Paris
Ja
Ich muss gerade nochmal kopieren.
Actions. Ich muss mich erstmal einloggen.
Continue with Twitch.
So. Add
to
Wupplors.
Leute, wie wollen wir das Emote nennen?
Ferris oder Rust?
Wir können auch
Custom-Emote für machen. Soll es Ferris
heißen oder soll es Rust heißen, das Emote?
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Kann man Alias für Emotes machen?
Geht das?
Das sind Ferris und Rust.
Da sind wir, Leute.
Wir könnten es auch playen.
Leute, ich nenne es...
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Was haltet ihr davon?
Was haltet ihr davon,
wenn wir das Emote...
Wenn wir das Emote so nennen.
Was haltet ihr davon?
Ist das nicht sogar noch viel besser als Rust?
Das heißt Blazingly Fast
setzt das Emote bei mir.
Wie gesagt, Blazingly Fast ist out
Hab ich gestern auf Github gelernt
Laserspeed heißt das jetzt
Nicht wundern, ich futter nebenbei meine Wassermelone und ein paar Walnüsse
So, please IDE starten.
Starte die verdammte IDE.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt
Ich will IDE spielen, genau
So, hat das mit USB jetzt funktioniert?
Dev
USB
Ne, Dev
Äh, Bus
USB
Moment, das gehört ja gut
Hast du schon das neue Windows 11 Update 26H2 angeschaut?
Ich hoffe, ich bleibe noch eine Weile davon verschont
Wobei es kann sein, dass ich das bekommen sollte letztens, oder?
Weil letztens hat mein Rechner neu gestartet und hat Windows-Updates gemacht.
Ist dabei abgekackt und hat dann gesagt, er reboote jetzt und macht es wieder rückgängig.
Vielleicht war das das ja.
Das klingt nach Windows, ja?
Permission denied.
Okay, Pseudo-Cargo-Rahmen.
Bam.
Ach so.
Ah, fuck.
Wie war das nochmal?
Pseudo-Keep-Environment.
Ähm.
Pseudo.
Enf.
Oh.
Stack Overflow.
manchmal immer noch Beste.
Minus E? Ist das Minus E?
Sudo Minus E?
Ja.
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Warum ist Cargo not found?
Ich, guck mal
Achso, ich bin dumm
Der Path wird interpoliert, bevor das hier läuft
Okay, das stimmt nicht
Okay, ähm
Äh, Sudo
Okay, dann weiß ich, was wir machen
Da müssen wir Pseudo, Pseudo Keep Path.
Reserve Path, genau diesen Mist da brauche ich.
Ja.
Excellent.
So.
Kann ich jetzt an Cargo run?
Alter, was?
Senior Linux Checkerman am Start hier.
Wieso? Ist doch richtig.
Warum findet er jetzt Cargo nicht?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Ah.
Und jetzt minus E.
Pass auf.
Bam.
Haha.
Und schon funktioniert es.
Exzellent.
Erstmal durchdrehen.
Okay.
Leute, das muss ich mir unbedingt copy-pasten.
Weil
das weiß ich nächstes Mal nicht mehr.
Aber dafür habe ich ja hier mein
Run-Script. Da kann ich das reinschreiben.
Ähm.
Bash
minus C.
Äh.
Sollte hier vielleicht mal
links klammern.
Wie oft habe ich jetzt eigentlich
Bash gerappt hier gerade?
Sudo minus E minus Cargo Run Sleep 1.
Excellent.
Geht das jetzt?
Aha.
Exquisite.
Wir machen mal kurz den Sleep ein bisschen größer.
Wir wollen ja nicht so sehr auf das USB-Device hämmern.
Okay, aber anscheinend geht das Öffnen des USB-Devices.
Guckt.
Robbing USB-Device.
Opened USB Device, claimed Interface, release interface, closing device.
Das sieht doch gut aus, oder? Sieht so aus, als würde es funktionieren.
Ja.
Und ich finde, wir haben das auch relativ unabhängig gemacht.
Da kann es...
Das ist ja wirklich das Schöne in Rust, muss man sagen.
Also Rust will explizite Error-Handling.
Du musst nicht raten, wirft das irgendeine Exception, was muss ich catchen oder sonst was.
Es gibt bei Rust zwei Varianten.
Entweder du händelst den Fehler oder du unwrappst und dein Programm crasht an Ort und Stelle.
Aber es gibt nicht so, wo geraten wird bei Rust.
Dafür artet es manchmal richtig krass aus, wenn du dann drei Matches ineinander genestet hast oder sowas.
Weitere, weitere Rust.
Eigentlich einen eigenen Error-Typ bauen.
Das ist was, was ich mit euch auch im Stream machen will.
Ich habe letztens was geguckt.
Stream Anyhow und This Error gibt es da irgendwie noch als Crates.
Das wollte ich mir angucken, weil das scheint wohl so the way zu sein, wie man Error-Handling in Rust macht.
das eine für custom error types und das andere wenn man wenn es einfach nur um
eine konsolen benachrichtigung geht
um highlight der to do nicht richtig aber doch macht er ja so
Steht hier eigentlich in dem Debug auch die ID drin, die er sucht?
Ne, ne?
Jetzt ist die Frage, kann man hier String Interpolation benutzen?
Ne
Manchmal funzt das in Rust
Ich glaube man muss Format dafür benutzen
Format
So
Genau das funzt
Da kann man jetzt nämlich sagen
Device not found
Und man sagt jetzt hier
Vendor
Genau
Product
Braucht man bei Rust immer ein Crate
für Async? Ja
Du hast in Rust in der Standard
Library nur die
ganzen Typen, die du brauchst, also du hast
ein Future Type, also das was
quasi so eine asynchrone Funktion zurückgibt
Async
ist ja nicht gleich Multithreading
Ich kann das jetzt nur am Beispiel von C-Sharp erklären.
Ich gehe aber mal ganz hart davon aus, dass es in Rust mehr oder weniger genauso ist.
Soll ich mal kurz versuchen zu erklären, so aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt jetzt, Leute,
was der Unterschied ist zwischen Async und Sachen parallel oder sagen...
Zeitgleich ausführen.
Multithreading nennen wir es.
Versus Multithreading.
Soll ich mal versuchen?
Geht es um den Heartbeat?
Ja, aber das ist nur Aufhänger
für ein bisschen Rust lernen.
Ich kann das mal probieren.
Wie gesagt,
im Detail habe ich mir das nur
für C-Sharp angeguckt, aber ich weiß,
das ist in Rust nicht
großartig unterschiedlich.
Es gibt zwei Varianten, wie man Logik, ich nenne es mal, parallel ausführen kann.
Nicht zeitgleich wirklich ausführen kann, zwangsläufig, ja.
Aber zum Beispiel, ihr wollt ein Web-Request machen und anstatt jetzt zu sagen,
ich mache den ersten Web-Request, warte bis der fertig ist, dann mache ich den zweiten Web-Request, warte bis der fertig ist, dann mache ich den dritten Web-Request.
Es gibt zwei Varianten, um mehrere Web-Requests gleichzeitig auszuführen.
Obwohl zeitgleich nicht wirklich stimmt, aber ich sage mal, parallel auszuführen.
Das eine ist Async-Await und das andere ist Multithreading.
Async-Await funktioniert, also Multithreading ist das einfachere von beiden tatsächlich.
Zum Programmieren ist Async-Comade einfacher, aber zum Erklären ist Multithreading deutlich einfacher. Multithreading bedeutet, die Requests werden einfach zeitgleich gestartet und laufen auf mehreren Kernen zeitgleich auf eurer CPU.
Request 1, 2, 3, 4
wird jeweils auf einem anderen Kern
zur gleichen Zeit ausgeführt
so richtig stimmen tut das nicht
da kommt der Scheduler vom OS noch dazwischen
der entscheidet auf welchem Kern
wie wo was ausgeführt wird
aber prinzipiell kann man sagen Multithreading ist
am einfachsten zu erklären
du nimmst einfach deine 3, 4 Webrequests
den Code, die Logik
die das ausführt
sagst ich starte das jetzt
und dann läuft das zeitgleich auf mehrere CPU-Kernen
komplett
parallel.
Und dann musst du dich
halt
selbst drum kümmern,
dass du nicht
auf ein Ergebnis zugreifst,
bevor das fertig ist, dass du nicht
nach drei
Requests schon aufhörst und auf den
vierten wartest. Also wenn du Multithreading machst,
musst du dich selbst um Synchronisieren kümmern.
So, wenn du das Ganze mit Async und Await machst, dann ist das in der Implementierung, also in der Library, ist das deutlich komplizierter.
Für euch ist es allerdings einfacher, weil mit Async und Await, wie ihr hier seht, könnt ihr mehr oder weniger Code schreiben, wie als wäre es synchron.
Anstatt Await sagt ihr hier Await?
Dann macht er erst das, dann macht er das.
Wie das hinter der Haube funktioniert ist.
Und ein großer Unterschied ist auch, wenn ihr Sachen habt, die viel CPU-Zeit verbrauchen, dann könnt ihr nur Multithreading machen, wenn ihr es beschleunigen wollt. Async-Await bringt euch da nichts. Async-Await bringt euch nur was, wenn ihr awaiten könnt, bis es ein Ergebnis gibt.
Also, gutes Beispiel ist, wir lesen eine Datei von der Festplatte. Wir schicken einen Request an einen Webserver und warten auf die Antwort. Dann könnt ihr sagen mit Ace and Great, jawohl, wir schicken jetzt den Request los.
dann
warte ich
bis ein Ergebnis zurückkommt
und in der Zwischenzeit schicke ich
schon mal, weil ich habe jetzt wieder
Ressourcen frei, den zweiten Request los
den dritten, den vierten Request los
und ich werde aufgeweckt
quasi wieder, ich await dann
auf das Result
vom Web-Request, so
das funktioniert intern
mit einer State-Machine
also im Prinzip
was an der Stelle hier passiert ist,
das ist eigentlich
kein Await, sondern das ist ein Return.
An der Stelle
ist ein Return. Also
der Code
wird ausgeführt, trifft
auf das Await, was an der Stelle
dann passiert ist,
eigentlich passiert hier ein Return.
Also die Funktion ist dann fertig erstmal.
Wenn dann das Ergebnis da ist von diesem List Devices, dann springt er wieder neu in die Funktion rein, macht allerdings dann hier mit dem Ergebnis weiter.
So, und ihr werdet jetzt natürlich feststellen, diese Funktion selbst hat überhaupt keine Struktur, dass die bei einem zweiten Aufruf was anderes macht als bei einem ersten Aufruf.
Die Funktion sieht für mich so aus, als macht die bei jedem Aufruf das gleiche. Und das ist das, warum du eine Async Runtime brauchst, die dafür sorgt, dass dieses State Management im Hintergrund gehandelt wird.
weil in Wirklichkeit passiert hier Magic
an der Stelle
deine Funktion wird umgeschrieben zu
an der Stelle hier einen Return
und hier drumherum einen If
so nach dem Motto If
Result
dann
quasi dahin so
also so sinngemäß
sowas baut Async und Await unter der
Haube aus eurer Funktion
das heißt
wenn hier Awaited wird
springt er hier raus, wenn das Ergebnis da ist, geht die Async Runtime hier wieder rein,
sieht, aha, Result ist gesetzt und macht an der Stelle weiter.
Also da wird im Hintergrund, wie man so schreibt, eine State Machine gebaut,
dass der Code Async Await mäßig so aussieht, wie als wäre es geschrieben für synchroner Code.
Also implementierungsmäßig und wie es funktioniert, würde ich sagen, ist Async Await viel komplizierter.
und
aber zum Schreiben ist Multithreading
komplizierter. So, zumindest ist das
in C Sharp so, wie ich euch das erzählt habe.
Ob das jetzt in Rust exakt genauso
ist, weiß ich nicht, aber ich gehe mal davon
aus, dass es kein allzu großes,
allzu großer Unterschied sein wird.
Async macht doch kein
aktives Polling.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es genau funktioniert,
mich würde allerdings wundern,
wie das
in manchen Fällen, wo es
eben keine Benachrichtigung in dem Sinn gibt,
funktionieren soll ohne Polling.
Manche Sachen musst du
sicherlich pollen, um zu gucken, ob ein Ergebnis
da ist.
Aber da kümmert sich ja dann deine
Async-Runtime drum.
Ja, Sachen, wo du irgendeinen
Callback kriegst, wenn es fertig ist, kann ich verstehen.
Aber ansonsten musst du ja pollen.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie es sonst funktionieren sollte.
Hallo.
Unterschied ist, Polling bedeutet, also wenn du pollst, das heißt du fragst immer in einem bestimmten Intervall an,
Hallo Request, hast du schon ein Ergebnis?
Und dein Request sagt immer, nein, nein, nein, ich laufe noch, ich laufe noch, ich laufe noch.
Und irgendwann frage ich beim Request an, er sagt, jawohl, hier ist deine Webseite.
Hier ist der Response, ich bin fertig.
So, Callback heißt, ich sage am Anfang, Request, auf geht's, fetch mir www.google.com und sag mir Bescheid, wenn du fertig bist.
Und du kannst mir Bescheid sagen, indem du diese Funktion bei mir wieder aufrufst.
Das sind so zwei unterschiedliche Sachen.
Das Ding ist aber halt, nicht alles, auf das man warten muss, unterstützt Callbacks.
Also bei manchen Sachen musst du pollen.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie man drum herum kommen soll.
Frag mich nicht, wie es bei allen Sachen im Detail funktioniert.
Keine Ahnung.
Warte mal, was trinken.
Ja, geht ja nicht auf Interrupt.
Und wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, wie es genau funktioniert, aber
letztendlich, irgendein
Callback muss dann trotzdem ja aufgerufen werden,
dass du Bescheid
gesagt bekommst, ja.
Das Betriebssystem wird wahrscheinlich
dann irgendwie Interrupt Handling machen und
dann bei dir irgendein Callback
aufrufen. Ey, keine Ahnung.
kennst du Rayon?
Habe ich ein Video drüber geguckt, ja?
Rayon ist
eine Rust Library.
Damit kannst du sagen,
zum Beispiel,
Tommy, du kennst dich damit besser aus,
aber sag mal, ob das stimmt.
Also wenn du jetzt hier
einen Vektor hast mit Zahlen,
so,
und wenn du den
normalerweise in Rust,
mal angenommen, by the way,
das geht in Go nicht,
weil die das nicht wollen, nicht weil Go das nicht könnte,
aber die wollen das nicht in der Standard-Library haben.
Ja, also du kannst in Rust jetzt sagen,
okay, ich will den Vektor
hier
filtern. Da kann ich sagen, Filter,
Filter,
und jetzt muss ich, glaube ich, sowas sagen,
wie, äh, i,
i größer 2.
Ja.
Wo stehen jetzt die
Referenzen oder so. Nochmal die Referenzen.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ich bin mir irgendwie... Keine Ahnung, ob das
genau stimmt, ob das der Weg ist,
das zu machen. So. Und jetzt kann ich das
filtern. Also ich gehe quasi
eins nach dem anderen.
Das ist quasi wie eine Vorschleife.
Gehe ich durch, gucke mir jedes
Element an, ob es größer als 2 ist
und gebe das dann zurück. So. Und mit
Rayon kannst du sowas machen wie
Iter Parallel oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann macht er diese Suche hier
nach den Elementen automatisch
multithreaded auf mehreren kernen da kannst du mit relativ easy code anpassungen ordentlich
blazing fast alles machen
können wir uns alle angucken chat
okay
da ist der netz wenn ich jetzt hier irgendein mist übergebe usb die weiß was es nicht gibt
dann er die weiß not found doch schick jetzt mal wieder so richtig und jetzt hat das gefunden
Okay, sehr schön.
Also, USB-Device ist geöffnet.
Let.
Was gebe ich denn hier zurück?
Interface.
Dann nennen wir es mal USB-Interface.
Willst du Zeile 14?
Ah ja, da weiß ich, Tommy, ich weiß, wie das funktioniert.
Pass mal auf.
Rust Hacker Man.
Ähm.
So?
Ist das richtig?
Gucken wir mal.
Äh.
Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht, Chat.
Could not compile.
Ach so.
Moment.
Ah ja, gut, guck jetzt, jetzt hat das hier Hex formatiert.
Ah, und wenn ich ein kleines X mache, macht er dann Lowercase.
Oh, das ist geil.
Excellent.
Äh, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Warum?
Ah, dann formatiert er das mit 0 davor noch.
Okay, das finde ich sogar noch schicker.
Ist halt schon ein bisschen Magic, ne?
Sehr gut.
Device not found.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz gucken.
FCF.
0 FCF.
So, okay.
USB-Device ist geöffnet.
Die nächste Question, die sich stellt ist ja, wie lese und schreibe ich denn jetzt das USB-Device?
Was hat USB-Interface denn für Methoden?
Ist das überhaupt sinnvoll, immer Interface 0 zu claimen?
Was ist, wenn das USB-Gerät mehrere hat?
Aber der Stick hat ja anscheinend nur eins.
Gibt es da sowas wie Write?
Gibt es schon mal nicht.
Endpoint.
Endpoint klingt gut.
Okay, ich muss in die Hilfe gucken.
Keine Ahnung.
N-USB-Examples
hatte man doch hier. Guck mal.
N-USB-Examples.
Da müsste doch was auf Browser
machen.
Bulk.io
Klingt doch schon mal gut.
Okay. Aha.
Endpoint
Out, das hatten wir in Go auch
Weil wir haben ja sowas ähnliches
Schon mal in Go gebaut
Ähm
Nicht irritieren lassen, dass das
Aussieht wie eine Python App
Hier ist eine normale Go App
Ja, guck mal
Irgendwo hier in Go haben wir doch sowas auch schon gemacht.
Äh, oder auch nicht.
Achso, nee, hier hatten wir nur Dump-Broadcast-Messages.
Ja, nee.
Das ist leider nicht so viel zu sehen in der Go-Variante davon.
Okay, guck mal hier.
Da sind jetzt auch wieder irgendwelche Magic...
Irgendwelche Magic-Adressen drin.
Keine Ahnung, ob das richtig ist.
Das kann man doch bestimmt auslesen.
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes.
Wir können doch bestimmt von diesem USB-Interface auslesen, was es kann, oder?
Das muss doch irgendwie gehen, weil ich kann ja nicht für alle Geräte der Welt wissen,
mit welchen Magic-Adressen man sie öffnen kann.
Was genau?
Ah, nee. Ich muss...
So, machen. Genau.
Also, was können wir denn bei dem USB-Interface so alles abfragen?
Control-In.
Nicht, dass das was ist, was wir haben wollen.
Release.
Descriptors. Endpoint.
Descriptor. Descriptors.
Des Kryptors klingt doch an sich schon mal ganz gut.
Schauen wir doch mal.
Machen wir eine Schleife da drüber.
By the way, Rust Rover, beste.
Interface.
Und jetzt debug-dumpen wir das einfach mal raus.
Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Okay, nice.
Was haben wir hier? Ah, guck mal, Endpoints
Da haben wir es doch, guck mal hier
Endpoint, Direction in
Transfer Type
Und das ist es
Es ist 0x01
Und nicht 0x02
Obvious, die Leute
Chat, ihr wusstet das bestimmt schon, oder?
Ist ja klar
Wir sind ja alle
Low-Level-USB-Kenner
Euch war das sicherlich klar, dass das hier
01 anstatt 02 sein muss
Hm.
Würde ich die Name
suchen lassen, wozu Hartkrauten?
Wurzelmeister,
danke für den Sub.
Wie würdest du das machen mit dem automatisch suchen lassen?
Was hältst du denn von sowas hier?
Match?
Descriptors?
Äh.
Ne.
So auf jeden Fall schon mal nett.
Ähm.
Filter?
Vielleicht?
Descriptor?
Oh, das wird jetzt aber eklig,
das automatisch suchen zu lassen.
Also, da würdest du sagen,
Endpoints?
Ich will ja nicht Filtern nach Endpoints.
Ich will ja im Endeffekt...
Es gibt doch so Filter-Map oder sowas.
Map will ich einfach nur haben.
Nur Map.
Endpoints haben wir jetzt.
Und dann will ich den ersten Endpoint, der Read kann, oder?
Ja, ja, sowas.
Genau, genau.
Ach, man kann direkt First machen?
Ah, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Jetzt kann ich First machen.
First.
Äh, First.
First gibt es nicht?
Wie?
Gibt es denn Last?
Hä?
Moment, warum gibt es Last und First gibt es nicht?
Ach so.
Wirklich nicht?
Kann ich vielleicht so machen?
Okay, first gibt's nicht
Ach, find muss man machen
Ah
Rust einfach zu Pfeifett für mich, ja
So, und jetzt gucken wir hier
Endpoint, direction
Oder wie war das?
Äh
Okay, nee.
Chat, jetzt bin ich gerade zu
pepega dafür.
Wie jetzt?
Ich hab das jetzt gemappt.
Das heißt, ich hab jetzt eine Liste
mit Endpoint.
Oder nicht?
Oder doch?
Nee, oder? Ich hab nicht...
Ich habe gar keine Liste mit Endpoints.
Kann das sein?
Oh Gott, Rust.
Wie voll...
Das ist...
Dieses Rust-Link ist das.
Ich habe gar keine Liste mit Endpoints.
Hier, oder?
Ich habe hier einen Iterator über Endpoints.
Wie kriege ich das denn jetzt in ein...
In eine Liste mit Endpoints?
Ich dachte, das...
Muss ich sowas vielleicht machen irgendwie?
Unpacken oder so?
Oder Into irgendwas?
Mach Flat Map.
So was gibt es auch.
Ah, Pfeiffer Time.
Jawohl.
Und jetzt sage ich Find.
Endpoint.
Direction.
Aha.
Max, kehre um.
Ich gehe jetzt erstmal auf Reddit.
Subreddit.
Subreddit Programming Circle Jerk
und poste einen Post über
Rust.
So nach dem Motto, ich weiß gar nicht,
warum ich so lange andere Sprachen verwendet
habe. Ich hätte schon viel früher mit Rust
starten sollen. Rust ist die beste Sprache,
die es gibt.
Altarion, danke schön für den Sub.
Moin. Leute, wenn euch
der Stream gefällt, ne?
Ich will keine Wärmung für Subscriptions
machen. Follows
freuen mich auch. Ich bin mega happy
und ich freue mich immer, wenn ich sehe, dass es euch gefällt.
Die Follow-Zahlen steigen, grüne Pfeile
nach oben zeigen.
Also wenn es euch gefällt und ihr in Zukunft
auch am Start sein wollt und mitbekommen wollt, wenn ich
online gehe, dann jetzt Follow drücken. Beste.
So, Direction
gleich.
Direction
in.
By the way,
ich wollte gerade sagen,
warum formatiert es das nicht um?
Und jetzt?
EP, EP in.
Ha?
Ach nee, das kommt jetzt ja in der Option.
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich wieder machen.
Okay.
Or.
Ähm.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn da eine gute Fehlermeldung für?
Äh.
USB.
die war es noch zu forst keine ahnung aber okay mal gucken ob das funst hier
okay es ist alles ist alles ohne fehlermeldung durchgegangen das ist schon mal gut das schon
gut sein epn und das gleiche machen wir jetzt für ep out und da sagen wir jetzt direction
Out.
Und die große Preisfrage ist jetzt,
ist
In Write und
Out Read oder
ist es aus der Sicht
aus der Sicht
vom Device oder aus der Sicht
vom Computer?
Ihr könnt auch nur raten, ne?
Weiß keiner so genau.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Äh, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Ich hab das ja noch gar nicht...
Ich hab das ja noch gar nicht geöffnet.
Kann man denn den...
Kann man denn den jetzt hier auch überhaupt öffnen?
Open?
Ne, das ist nur der Descriptor.
Open geht hier gar nicht.
Oder?
Ne, na okay, das ist ein bisschen doof gemacht.
Also das heißt hier...
Das heißt, ich muss hier noch irgendwie
Desk Description
oder so hinschreiben. Und jetzt müssen wir
nämlich erst öffnen.
Jetzt müssen wir nämlich sagen,
EP out.
Specify
Full Path. Okay.
Warum ist es hier Transfer Out
und hier ist es Direction Out?
Wir hinterfragen das einfach nicht.
Das ist FyFet USB Logik.
Aber da können wir jetzt Address sagen, oder?
Address.
Oh, Leute.
Es funzt.
Komm, es wird sogar unwrapped.
Aber unwrapped brauchen wir nicht, da können wir einfach ein Fragezeichen nennen.
Also das muss ich sagen, ich war am Anfang, als ich mir das vor, das gibt es jetzt ja auch noch nicht so lange mit dem Fragezeichen,
vor fünf Jahren oder so mal angeguckt habe, fand ich das erst sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Aber vor allem, weil ich das mit dem Return-Type hier oben gar nicht gecheckt habe.
Aber mittlerweile finde ich es sehr nice, dass man einfach ein Fragezeichen hinten dran machen kann.
Also für alle, die nicht dabei waren vorhin, Fragezeichen an der Stelle macht folgendes.
das guckt sich den return wert an von der funktion die vor dem fragezeichen steht und
wenn er return werden result ist und das result nicht okay ist wird das an der stelle automatisch
mit dem error da spare ich mir quasi ein komplettes match oder ein if drumherum ziemlich nice
du hast dieses system das ist aber das feature schlechthin warum man was verwendet
weil ohne das
kann sich was anderes verwenden
Also das ist ja der Aufhänger von Rust gewesen.
Dass du ohne aufwendige, also Performance-fressende Runtime-Checks so viel Memory-Safety wie möglich kriegst.
Also das ist der Sinn dahinter, warum Rust erfunden wurde.
Und wenn du sagst, du brauchst dieses Borrow System nicht
Dann kannst du dir, guck dir anderes Zeug an
Zum Beispiel
Ja gut
Du hast ja noch
Du hast ja noch sowas wie SICK oder C
Meinetwegen auch, ihr wisst, ich hasse C++
Aber meinetwegen auch C++
Aber Rust ohne Borrow Checker und so
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Selbstvermögen, es gibt es nicht ohne
oder aber, weißt du was?
Wie wär's mit Go?
Go ist eine super Sprache.
Go ist ohne Scheiß
eines der produktivsten Sprachen, die es gibt
und die beste
Sprache für Binaries,
also für
easy deploybare Anwendungen unter Linux.
Es gibt nichts einfacheres
wie Go Binaries.
Und
Ob Go jetzt einen Garbage-Collector hat oder nicht, ganz ehrlich, drauf geschissen.
Für die meisten Anwendungen ist das vollkommen egal, was die Performance angeht.
Also wenn dir Rust nicht gefällt, wegen Borrowing, dann Go.
Da bist du von Haus aus Memory-Safe unterwegs.
Es hat auch ein riesen Ökosystem.
Oder was sagst du, Bugelkuch?
Oder muss das unbedingt Rust sein?
Weil wenn es unbedingt Rust sein muss, dann...
Da musst du mit dem Borrow-Checker irgendwie klarkommen.
So.
Mal EP-Out-Description.
EP-In-Description.
Address.
Chat, fällt euch irgendwie was auf,
wie man das vielleicht noch ein bisschen schöner machen könnte?
Das ist jetzt schon ziemliches Geschwubbel hier, oder?
Tommy weiß das bestimmt.
Der macht das in einem One-Liner.
Und dann sagt er, easy as fuck.
So.
Aber wie...
Also, was mir da gerade auffällt,
was wir ja machen könnten, ist,
dieses Interface hier,
OpenUSB,
ähm,
das können wir in die,
ich wollte gerade sagen, das können wir doch sogar in die Funktion
auslagern hier.
Weil uns interessiert doch,
uns interessieren doch letztendlich
eigentlich
nur,
nur
die Interfaces.
Nicht die Interfaces.
Die Endpoints interessieren uns doch nur.
Der Rest ist uns doch eigentlich egal.
Das heißt, wir können das hier reinmachen.
Awaken das Ganze.
Und dann returnen wir.
Okay, jetzt ist Rust 5-Head-mäßig gefragt.
Kann man in Rust
mehr als 1
returnen.
Also kann man zum Beispiel sowas hier machen.
Sowas hier.
Aha, so.
Also da muss ich jetzt aber auch sagen, okay.
Ah ne, Moment.
Okay.
So.
Ey, tatsächlich? Das Funst?
Was will er von mir?
Das kann er... Das will er...
Das will er doch jetzt nicht ernsthaft, dass ich das in die Signatur reinschreibe, oder?
Wenn ich das in die Signatur reinschreibe, kann er keine Sau mehr lesen.
Kann man irgendwie tricksen?
hier und kann hier sagen,
Amma-Score.
Mega.
Naja, anscheinend nicht.
Naja.
Ah.
Oh, das ist natürlich eine gute Idee.
Also heißt im Endeffekt
introduce local variable
Die Variable ist jetzt vom Typ
Ah, Moment mal, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Ne, Sekunde, warte mal, warte mal,
ich bin gerade noch verwirrt.
Hier, so.
Die Variable ist jetzt vom Typ
EndpointBulkIn
EndpointBulkOut
out. Das heißt, wir könnten
jetzt sowas hier sagen. Type
Open USB
Wie nennen wir das?
Ähm
Endpoint
So?
Geht das?
Bissi hässlich ist es, ne?
Aber...
Hahaha.
Aber das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich funktionieren.
Open USB Endpoints.
Und jetzt sage ich, okay.
Kappa HD XD.
Funst!
Und was mache ich jetzt mit dem Return-Type?
Das ist nicht wirklich USB-Interface?
Öh!
Öh, das heißt 0 und 1, das kann man nicht benennen.
Doch, das kann man bestimmt irgendwie benennen, oder?
Kann man, kann man sagen...
Blub?
Fuck!
Kann man das nicht benennen?
Ja, dann ist das ziemlich useless.
Oh, das ist ja eklig.
Rust named tupless.
Doesn't have named tupples.
Okay.
Ja, ja, okay.
Instruct kann ich machen.
Ja.
Gut.
Lul.
So schlau bin ich auch.
Gibt es da vielleicht schon irgendwas, was fertig ist?
Endpoint.
Endpoint Descriptor.
Endpoint Read.
Ah, Leute.
Pfeifhäder!
Pfeifhäder-Idee!
Wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Massive Pfeifhäder-Idee!
Massive!
Pass mal auf!
Massive Pfeifhäder-Idee!
Pause-Champ!
Pause-Champ ruhig!
Ich muss mal kurz vorher in mein Toastbrot noch reinbeißen.
Wir machen jetzt!
Der Scheiß kommt weg!
Struckt!
Den Go schreiben.
Dead Girl.
Wir haben das letzte Mal doch schon den Go gemacht.
Hier.
Struckt.
USB-Device.
Okay.
HiFat.
Ihr wisst, worauf ich raus will.
Hoffe ich.
ähm,
FN, jetzt muss ich diesen Mist hier mal
irgendwie kopieren.
Ne, Moment mal, Moment mal, Moment mal, Moment mal,
wir sind in Rust, wir sind in Rust, Sekunde.
Impel,
das machen wir dann in eine eigene Datei,
USB-Device,
so,
diesen Scheiß brauchen wir hier nicht mehr,
hier,
returnen wir jetzt
ein
USB-Device.
Ne, Self-Return wäre hier.
Oder? Self.
Self-Return. Also das ist ein USB-Device.
Hm.
So, und USB-Device hat
folgende
Member.
Weiß nicht, ob das in was so heißt.
EPN.
Das ist einmal das Ding.
Ah, ich kopiere mir das mal kurz.
also es hat einmal epn das ist diese dieses hässliche ding hier
moment ich bin ich bin zu feifell gewesen war damals n usb interface
Oh fuck
Device Endpoint
Device
Oh fuck
Endpoint
So hier so
EP in
Und EP out
ep out okay so das kommt weg
sergeant silva dankeschön für den sub
huge subscriptions
So, guckte mal hier
So, und jetzt sagen wir hier unten
Return, Self
Also Self ist in dem Fall immer
Referenz auf das eigene
Wie ist das denn eigentlich in Rust schöner?
Sagt man hier Self oder
USB Device? Machen tut es das gleiche
self ist also generic ep in und ep out fertig ach so und das müssen wir jetzt noch in ein
okay reppen sehr gut sagt das muss auch nicht mut sein und jetzt kriegen wir den usb device
und jetzt kann ich hier sagen usb device sagt zack open usb
und jetzt habe ich hier
ein USB-Device, zack,
mit EP-in, EP-out.
Ist das nicht nice?
Ich sag doch, Leute, Five Head
war das jetzt. Das war
Five Head-Idee, also
High-IQ-Ideen-Counter, beziehungsweise
Pool ist
jetzt aufgebraucht für heute.
Also auf mehr schlaue Sachen komme ich heute nicht mehr.
Was es wird?
Ich werde Deutschlands Nummer 1 Rust-Streamer.
Und Deutschlands Nummer 1 C++-Hater.
Deutschlands Nummer 1 C++-Hater bin ich schon.
Ne, was es wird?
Wir lesen ein USB-Device aus.
Oder wir versuchen, ein USB-Device auszulesen.
ok so usb device jetzt haben wir hier ep in zeit immer noch die frage ich bin mir sicher was jetzt
wo man jetzt wirklich redet und wo man arbeitet aber wir können das ja mal hier gucken ep in
ok ep out ist anscheinend right also ist aus der sicht das ist aus der sicht vom
host ep out wird gerettet sehe ich das sehe ich das richtig
andere wir anreppen überhaupt nichts jolo fand wo siehst wo siehst du hier
an rap wir haben kein einziges an rap nach dem example
weil wir produzieren hier nur errorfree clean rust first try ohne fehler
ja ich putte wieder mal ein torsbruch
ok also jetzt schreiben wir mal was in das usb device rein
wir schreiben jetzt mal in einem schritt rein okay
noch besser chat noch besser wäre es wenn wir eine reit methode hätten auf usb device oder
und nicht direkt den dass die in der interne funktionalität sachen exposen bei the way was
hat er für Schmerzen.
Cannot borrow immutable local variable.
Achso. Muss ich das hier
mut machen? Mut.
So, jetzt schreiben wir was in das
USB-Device rein. Irgendwelche random Sachen.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Ob das jetzt was bringt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Und jetzt sagen wir epout.
What? Alter, was ist das für
ne...
Das ist ja eine grausame
RP aus der Hölle, Alter.
Ja, Duration können wir schon mal importieren.
Okay, ich lasse
das jetzt einfach mal laufen und gucken, was passiert.
Bäm!
Es hat wohl funktioniert.
Hm.
Hat er auch was geschrieben?
Hier, Submitted.
5 Bytes hat er geschrieben auf Endpoint 1.
Flasche die Endpoints.
Muss man anscheinend nicht machen, oder?
Wahrscheinlich macht...
Das macht er hier schon, oder?
Wait for...
Wait for completion. Ich glaube nicht, dass man das braucht.
Flasch?
Das macht er unter der Haube wahrscheinlich schon.
AI in den Einstellungen deaktiviert?
Ne.
Aber wir wipecodeen nichts.
Das einzige, was wir machen, ist, wir fragen mal ein paar kleine Sachen.
Als Stackoverflow-Ersatz.
So.
Also wir können jetzt was schreiben in das Device.
Also schön ist das noch nicht.
Da sollten wir vielleicht eine eigene Write-and-Read-Methode dann bauen.
Aber jetzt lesen wir erstmal was aus dem USB-Device.
So.
ep in wisst ihr was wir ich habe keinen bock dass ich jedes mal usb device davor schreiben muss wenn
ich ehrlich bin deswegen machen jetzt einfach mal letzt ep in gleich usb die weiß da wird er
jetzt natürlich meckern wird das natürlich meckern aber danach kann ich das die weiß
nicht mehr verwenden, weil es hier rausgemoved wird.
Egal. Zum Testen.
Was?
What?
Würdest du
deaktivieren, da nicht nur dein
Stream, sondern auch der Chat
davon genutzt wird?
Was?
Moment, von welcher AI sprechen wir?
Ich dachte, du meinst jetzt, weil ich
in den Stream geschrieben habe, in den Titel geschrieben habe,
ganz ohne Vibe-Coding. Twitch-AI.
Moment, Twitch hat jetzt auch AI?
Was ist das?
Warum hat Twitch
Wer hat denn bitte schön AI jetzt noch auf Twitch gebraucht?
Okay
Okay, das mach ich nachher auf
Das mach ich nachher aus
Ach, das ist
Na, sehr nett
Das Ganze ist Opt-Out und nicht Opt-In
Na gut, wenn es Opt-In wäre
Dann würde es wahrscheinlich keiner machen, ne?
Und das wollten die umgehen
und haben gesagt, she baited, einfach opt out.
Logisch.
Oh, guck mal, hat der jetzt eigentlich was gelesen?
Hat der jetzt was gelesen?
Aus dem, aus dem...
Oh.
Der ist gepanicked, Leute, zwischendurch.
an rep option 0 ja okay der der kann nichts lesen
Ähm
Wartet mal, ich bin gerade echt ein bisschen
planlos
Was hier eigentlich passiert
Also
Also das ist ein Buffer
ep in pending erst mal endlos schleifen stellt
das dass das mit so hoch wie von stars da irgendwie anders an ried reader
Oh, Reader klingt gut.
Da muss ich selbst nichts machen, oder?
Reader? Buffer Size?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
4096 oder so.
Await? Ist das eine gute Idee?
Nee, oder? Kannst du nicht awaiten.
Das ist...
Sagt blödes Zeug.
Was haben wir denn? Set Name...
With Read Timeout?
Okay, äh, sagen wir
Duration... Was ist nicht Duration?
New. Duration
from
seconds. Sag mal eine Sekunde
Timeout, ja.
Reader.
Ja, Read würde ich sagen.
Ah, es gibt ein Read Tokyo für Async Read
und ein Read.
Wir machen mal das synchrone Read jetzt.
Einfach nur mal zum
checken, ja.
ob der, ob der irgendwas
readet.
Read? So, da brauchen wir
irgendeinen Buffer für.
Let, mut.
Wie ist nochmal die Syntax für Arrays
in Rust? Das ist doch irgendwie
sowas wie
Buffer. Ach, guck mal. Hier, KI-Stells.
High IQ.
Ja, komm, wir machen mal.
Komm, es reicht. Acht.
Acht. Ne, ein. Ein Byte.
Ein Byte, es reicht.
erstmal zu gucken ob es funktioniert so read buff await geht das funktioniert nicht jetzt muss man
das importieren import standard i o read okay das muss man natürlich nicht erwarten standard
I'll read.
Der Reader funktioniert, weil er nicht mutt ist.
Okay.
Unused size.
Let.
Size.
Ja.
Okay, jetzt machen wir mal Debug.
Debug, Size.
Und gucken mal, ob der irgendwas liest.
Oder ob der einfach nur timeoutet.
Was will er jetzt hier?
Unused result.
Ja, ja.
Bam.
Guck mal.
Der hat tatsächlich was gelesen vom USB-Interface.
Da gucken wir doch mal.
Da gucken wir doch mal, was der gelesen hat vom USB-Interface.
Hier, 164.
Was auch immer es zu bedeuten hat.
Aber 164 liest er.
lesen wir mal 16 16 bytes
alles klar
wir kriegen eine antwort vom usb interface was auch immer das bedeutet
Kann ich jetzt sagen,
das kann ich hier sagen, Format?
Und jetzt quasi,
wie war das?
Doppelpunkt X, so?
Naja.
Okay.
Hm.
Wie kann ich denn den Buffer jetzt dumpen lassen
gescheit?
Vielleicht so einfach?
So mit dem Fragezeichen hinten dran?
Äh...
Nee, ich will es ja in Hex.
Ich will es in Hex.
Nicht in Dezimal.
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Moment, da ist nochmal ein Ausrufezeichen.
Wo kommt das her?
Hä?
Nee, es ist Format.
Es ist so abhängig dumm, Alter.
Guck mal hier.
Äh
Sieht aber nicht schön aus
Und was ist, wenn man jetzt macht
Doppelpunkt
Ähm
Punkt 2
Geht das? Sieht das besser aus dann?
Ja
Oder 0,2
Dann ist es immer zweistellig, ne?
Nee.
Moment, wie sorge ich dafür,
wie sorge ich dafür, dass es immer zweistellig ist?
Und immer 0 davor hat?
Nicht so?
Doppelpunkt 2.
Ah, das kann sein, dass man gar keinen Punkt braucht.
Ah ja.
Okay, das ist auch schön.
Also, wie klingt...
A4! Das ist ein N-Plus-Frame. Ich habe einen N-Plus-Stick per USB da gerade dran.
Kann man beispielsweise Herzschlag-Sensoren auslesen oder Pedale vom Fahrrad oder irgendwie...
Was gibt es denn da noch so?
Umdrehungen, wie schnell man gerade tritt auf dem Fahrrad und sowas.
Das ist ein
End-Plus-Frame
Da fragen wir doch mal
Das hat ja mit Vibe-Koordinatix zu tun
Was bedeutet
Dieser End-Plus-Frame
Das muss ja ein Error-Frame sein
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Ein gültiges End-Plus-Kommando ist
Ja, das sieht nach einem
End-Plus-Broadcast-Datenpaket aus
Was?
Ein Broadcast-Datenpaket?
Ich glaube, JetGPT ist wieder mal richtig Müll.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Wir können nur FreeKI verwenden.
Okay, okay, der ist zu dumm.
Der ist, ChatGPT checkt es nicht.
Es geht nur bis hier.
Ah, dann ist es eindeutig.
Ich finde auch diese, mittlerweile gehen mir diese Standardredewendungen von den ganzen KIs voll auf den Sack.
Die sagen dann, also gerade Chat-GPT sagt in letzter Zeit immer sowas wie, ah, dann müssen wir einmal ehrlich auf die Vor- und Nachteile schauen.
Und sowas, das ist so ein dummes Gelaber.
Aber für sowas ist das praktisch.
Also, Payload-Länge, Message-ID.
Jetzt verstehe ich das, die Antwort
Guck mal, ich krieg ne Bestätigung
Ich krieg ne Bestätigung
Dass ich Müll geschickt habe, kann das sein?
Ich krieg die Sachen hier wieder zurück im Payload
Wir schenken mal 5, 5, 5, 5 hin.
Ja.
Ich krieg die Bestätigung, dass ich das hingeschickt hab.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, da kommt mit meinem Payload nicht so ganz klar, was ich da hinschicke.
Komm, wir schicken nochmal mehr hin.
Ich glaube, der ist ein wenig verwirrt
über das, was ich an ihn schicke
Da kann er mit nichts anfangen
Dann tun wir doch mal so
als wüssten wir, was wir machen
und schicken da mal was Sinnvolles hin
Also einen Endframe
enthält immer
am Anfang
A4. Also das kann ich schon mal
da reinschreiben.
Es ist immer A4
gefolgt
von
Message ID
Ja.
ChatGPT kann sich übrigens nicht entscheiden.
Also es ist
okay.
Das ist dieses Sync-Byte.
Da kommst du nicht drum herum.
Syncbyte, Payload Length
und dann Message ID.
Message. Da müssen wir gucken, was das für...
Was ist
für eine...
Endplus
AE
Message ID.
wir gucken jetzt einfach mal github message id n plus da gibt es bestimmt irgendwelche
irgendwelche libraries für keine ahnung arduino oder so gibt es bestimmt
komm mal n plus arduino klingt doch schon mal gut gibt es da vielleicht ein paar
enums oder so wo man mal gucken könnte
defines messages types types types types types klingt gut
data page ok gibt es nicht ich glaube nicht dass ich hier was drin entdefinen vielleicht
Ah.
Okay, AE gibt es nicht.
AE ist die Message-ID.
Das ist nicht dasselbe wie die...
Was bedeutet
die Message-ID?
ist es bei nicht die normale podcast data message id ja ich weiß was ist es denn
gehört zum bereich der erweiterten endnachrichten ist nicht einfach okay ich glaube ich glaube mein
gerät möchte mir damit sagen mit einer antwort dass die daten die ich geschickt haben bullshit
sind.
Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus, okay?
Also sprich, wenn da AE steht bei Message
Type, ist das, du bist dumm.
Wir schicken da jetzt mal was
Sinnvolles hin. Also, wie war das
Ganze aufgebaut?
Payload Length? Okay, machen wir mal
Payload Length 1.
Message ID.
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt mal
genau nachgucken, wie ein Reset aussieht.
Wir hatten
doch hier End plus
Go. Da können wir uns noch ein bisschen was
abgucken auf GitHub.
Wie die das bei
Go gemacht haben.
Da vielleicht ein bisschen was
übersichtlicheres.
Device
Driver vielleicht?
USB?
USB Go?
Device?
Device Go?
Ja, wo kommt
das her? Wo kommt hier das
Guck mal hier, Reset
System Reset Message
Wo kommt das her?
End, hier kommt das bestimmt her
Constance
Also AE kennt der auch nicht
Ja, guck mal
Byte
Message System Reset
Okay, können die sich mal entscheiden
Okay
Okay, also, das ist die Reset-Message.
Also wir brauchen jetzt...
Okay, Payload-Length 1.
Message-ID 4.
Das ist ja auch verwirrend, guck mal.
4A ist die Message-ID für Reset.
A4 ist der Sync-Frame.
So, und jetzt müssen wir sonst noch hinschicken.
Einfach nur ein Byte noch.
0.
So, und jetzt noch eine Checksumme.
Wie berechnet man die Checksumme
davon?
Okay, mal gucken, was jetzt...
Guck mal, was gucken wir jetzt als Antwort.
Wir kriegen wieder
AE als Antwort.
AE heißt wahrscheinlich echt so viel
wie Bullshit.
Okay, wie berechnet man?
Da muss ich tatsächlich nochmal.
Ich brauche eine Rust-Funktion zum Berechnen der Checksum.
Das hat also mit Vibe-Cone nichts zu tun.
Okay, and Checksum.
So, einfach nur zum Ausprobieren.
What the fuck?
So, was macht der hier?
Data, U8, Checksum, Byte.
Also heißt im Endeffekt, ich sag jetzt hier, Endchecksum, Moment.
Die Checksum darf ja logischerweise nicht selbst mit.
Data, die darf ja nicht selbst mit gechecksumt werden, das geht ja gar nicht.
Wäre ja Endlosschleife.
So, wir sagen jetzt hier Data.
Let checksum and checksum data.
Okay, nur ein Borrow heißt das ja bei Go.
Jetzt sagen wir Data, Push, noch die Checksum hinten dran.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier in Data alles drin, was wir brauchen.
Und wir können das
Submit und mal gucken, was jetzt zurückkommt.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ah!
Guckt mal da!
Da kommt nicht AE zurück, sondern was
Sinnvolles jetzt.
Explain Endframe.
Okay, also.
Sync.
payload length message id payload checksum aha ok 6f es ist eine antwort auf einen reset
Okay
Alles klar
Okay, Leute, ich würde sagen, es hat funktioniert
Wir haben mit unserem USB-Gerät geredet
Wir schicken, wir schicken hin
Send, Reset
Und wir kriegen
Wir kriegen als Antwort
Ein
Jawohl, Reset wurde bestätigt
So, jetzt würden wir das Ganze natürlich
nur noch ein bisschen ordentlicher machen
weil da blickt Kassau durch
Jetzt brauche ich
wie gesagt meine
meine 5 IQ-Punkte sind
aufgebraucht gewesen mit meiner Idee
hier ein USB-Device-Truck anzulegen
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also
Wo
würde ich jetzt
Konstanten am besten
speichern?
Also wir gehen mal davon aus, wir brauchen
ein neues Modul,
was wir
Endplus nennen.
Und da drinnen will ich in der Datei so was wie
Constants haben, wo ich dann
so Sachen wie Syncbyte oder so was
reinschreiben kann.
Oder Message Types und so was.
Ne, ah, ich weiß was wir
Wir machen erstmal, Leute, wir machen erstmal
einen Inam, wir machen erstmal
einen Inam and
Message Type
So, und da haben wir
sowas wie
Ich hatte doch hier irgendwie sowas, wo die ganzen
hier Message
System Reset
haben wir da zu bieten
Okay, das schreiben wir klein, alles gut
Und der ist
X04.
Kann man das in Rust auch so machen?
Ah, der ist funzt.
Sehr gut.
Ist Rust so schlau und checkt,
dass das ein U8 ist?
Ne.
Hm.
Äh, kann man vielleicht sowas hier machen?
U8?
Äh.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das finden wir gleich raus, wie das funktioniert.
Dass wir dem Inam sagen, deine Werte sind Bytes.
So, also wir machen jetzt hier Message Type.
Und dann brauchen wir noch irgendwas für Konstanten.
Nächste, ne, okay.
Dann kommt jetzt nächste Rust Basic Sache.
Rust Modules.
Wie funzt das?
Modules.
Rust by Example.
Mod my mod.
Ne, ich will ja...
Ich will ja...
Hierarchie.
Ach, wie auch immer.
Okay, guck mal hier.
My Ordner.
Also wir machen einen Ordner, der heißt
Endplus.
Jetzt bin ich aber ein bisschen verwirrt.
Ich bilde mir ein, früher gab es sowas wie mod.rs.
Braucht man das jetzt nicht mehr?
Rust mod.rs?
Ja doch, das gab es früher.
Aha, name.rs versus name mod.rs.
Weil ich erinnere mich noch daran, Modules ging irgendwie so.
Du kannst sagen Directory and plus.
und da drin hast du
ein Mod.rs
angelegt.
Oder wie auch immer.
Mod.rs
Warum ist das
invalid?
Okay, dann
keine Ahnung.
Dann nenne ich das jetzt
Constance.
So, mal gehen.
Fuck.
Modul Declaration missing.
Ja, geil.
Ja.
Und jetzt?
Äh.
Okay, da bin ich zu dumm für.
Wie bringe ich
Rust Rover jetzt bei?
Hast du deinen
MikroTik-Router-Firmware schon geupgradet.
Wieso gibt's wieder...
Ich hab das nicht so verfolgt. Gibt's wieder...
Oh Gott.
Ey, gibt's da zu tun für?
Ey, gibt's wieder Sicherheitslücken?
Da gibt's eine Sicherheitslücke.
Der SSH hab ich gar nicht an.
Ich dachte, ich muss jetzt hier
einen Mod... Ich dachte, ich muss hier jetzt
Mod.rs anlegen. Aber das ist nicht erlaubt.
Wie mache ich das jetzt?
Also die neue
Benahmung ist, ich bräuchte jetzt
ein Endplus.
Warte mal, ich bräuchte jetzt
Endplus.rs, oder?
So bräuchte ich das jetzt.
Attach File to N Plus
RS. Aha.
Okay. Oh, das ist aber eklig.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Mit Mod RS. Chatgear für die Rust.
Tommy, falls du noch am Start bist.
Ähm.
Mod Punkt RS oder
diese neue Benahmung mit den
mit den Files.
Gibt es noch sowas,
dass ich hier sagen kann? Create Module.
Aber pass mal auf, ich mach jetzt direkt 17.
Ich verschieb das einfach hier rein.
Oh, Refactor.
Jetzt sagen wir Rename.
Mod.rs. Hier wird übrigens nicht gesucht.
Ha!
She baited!
Moment, warum habe ich das jetzt komplett in Mod.js umbenannt?
WTF?
Was?
And plus...
Okay, besser.
Was?
Module?
Irgendwas mache ich verkehrt.
Ah ja, hier, Mod.
End-Plus. Jetzt ist doch alles richtig so.
Ist doch alles gut. Passt doch.
So. Was haben wir hier?
Constance. Da kann ich jetzt nämlich zum Beispiel
sowas anlegen wie... Also,
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher, ob das eine ordentliche
Variante ist, das so zu machen in
Rust, ne? Aber ich würde jetzt
einfach so sagen, die Public...
Public
Const
U8. Ne, ähm...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Sync.
Hier, Sync.
Ja.
Ich würde es aber nicht Message TX Sync nennen,
sondern nur TX Sync, weil es ist ja keine Message.
Message sind nur Sachen, die
im Message-ID-Slot
U8
gleich A4. So, hä?
Ah ja, das Funds.
War es denn A4?
A4. So, das heißt
jetzt, wie greife ich da jetzt aus
Main drauf zu.
Wie greife ich
da auf Main jetzt drauf zu?
Kann ich jetzt einfach sagen?
PX
Sync
Äh, End
Was?
Äh
Ah, ich muss bestimmt sagen
Public Mod, oder?
Dass das funktioniert?
Oder gibt es noch mehr? Was gibt es
da noch alles. Pup?
Trade, Self, Super?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich mach einfach nur Pup mal davor.
Constance?
X?
Okay, das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Haben wir auch gerade, haben wir schon gelernt, wie man Module
machen in Rust. Wie gesagt,
es scheint nicht der neueste, die neueste
Variante zu sein, Module zu machen
mit Mod-AS.
anscheinend macht mir jetzt irgendwie
eine Datei, die so heißt, die dann
da drin liegt, was irgendwie eklig ist.
Weiß auch nicht.
So, Message ID.
Kann ich jetzt sagen, Message
ID?
Fände cool, wenn es zumindest noch ginge.
N plus, N plus RS zu haben.
Ja, das geht doch, oder?
Geht das nicht?
Doch, oder? Gibt's überhaupt kein Problem.
Kannst du machen.
Das muss ich,
Da muss ich mir mal irgendeinen Webcast oder so zu angucken, wie da jetzt Best Practice ist, wie man das macht.
So, aber kann ich denn jetzt sowas hier sagen?
End Message Type.
Aber nicht anstelle von Mod-RS.
Nee, soweit ich das gesehen habe, hast du, du, das stimmt.
Du hast nur zwei Sachen zur Auswahl.
Entweder du machst Mod-RS in dem Verzeichnis.
Verzeichnis oder du lässt Mod-RS in dem Verzeichnis weg, dann brauchst du allerdings
AND-plus-RS im Verzeichnis oben drüber, was ich aber auch eklig finde.
Was anderes geht nicht.
Cannot find value AND-Message-Type. So, da ist es doch. Was hat der jetzt für Probleme?
Äh, achso
Hä?
Warum, warum
Okay, kann das Ding, kann man das irgendwie
Konvertieren into
Ne
Who
Okay, wie, wie wandle ich jetzt meinen
I-Namen um
In ein U8
Kann ich, kann man
Warte mal, man kann doch Sachen implementieren
Für
I-Names, ne
Ja. Und da kann ich jetzt sagen,
FN U U8.
Das müsste eigentlich
funktionieren.
Jetzt, äh, und jetzt?
Okay, gut, jetzt aber die Frage, wie wandle ich das
hier drinnen um? Gibt es
irgendwie sowas wie U8 Pass oder so?
Ne.
Äh.
Ähm.
Hahaha.
Tja.
Aber wir haben zumindest schon mal eine Funktion.
2U8.
Rust Enum 2U8.
How to convert Enum into U8 in Rust.
Das ist genau das, was ich wissen will.
SU8.
Also kann ich im Endeffekt jetzt einfach sagen
Self
SU8
SU8 ist Invalid
Warum ist das
Warum ist das Invalid
Okay jetzt habe ich Copy und Clone
Derived, weiß nicht warum aber das hat anscheinend auch nichts gebracht
Try the referencing before cast.
Ah.
Repre U8.
Okay, wofür genau ist das jetzt gut?
Also die Referenzen müssen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ah, das heißt, dass man keine größeren...
Das ist nur so ein Save, dass man keine größeren Werte als 255 reinschreiben kann wahrscheinlich, ne?
Weil ansonsten wird der wahrscheinlich, wenn er ein U16 oder so casten will, zu einem U8,
gibt es dann vielleicht hier einen Runtime-Fehler oder schneidet das ab oder irgendwie.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Moment, aber es gibt doch garantiert irgendeinen Trade in Rust, dass ich Sachen in U8 konvertieren kann,
dass ich nicht sowas brauche wie to u8.
Gibt's
da nicht sowas?
Dass man sagen kann,
doch into gibt es doch.
Man kann doch bestimmt sowas sagen wie
into
for
message type.
So, bam.
Add missing.
Achso.
Was? Into? Achso.
U8 dann wahrscheinlich. Into u8
for message type.
Into, self, into, okay
Und jetzt sage ich einfach self
U8, bam
Beziehungsweise self
S U8
Und das kann ich mir schenken
Fragezeichen
Und jetzt into
Ah
Ja, das ist ja schick
Also Rust hat schon gewisse schöne Seiten, muss man sagen.
Okay, Rust Imp into, mal gucken, ob es dazu irgendwie Best Practices gibt.
From.
From and into Trades are inherently linked.
If you are able to convert the from trade.
Ah.
Ah, okay.
Das heißt, man soll lieber from implementieren.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Also ich soll nicht into implementieren, sondern lieber from.
So, das heißt, wir konvertieren jetzt ROM and Message to U8.
Ah ne, from.
Und dann kann ich jetzt hier sagen, Item SU8, okay.
Okay, das ist anscheinend die schönere Variante.
Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Sehr gut.
Ja gut.
Das finde ich schick, dass das hat irgendwie was.
Das Copy, brauche ich das?
Das brauche ich später wahrscheinlich, gell?
Weil...
Na gucken wir mal, ich lasse das mal weg.
from
und ja das hier dann,
weil es keine Referenz ist.
Und dann kann ich es nicht zweimal benutzen.
Aber, weil, guck mal,
wenn ich jetzt nochmal sowas machen will,
also sagen wir jetzt mal so,
hier, keine Ahnung, let,
das da, so.
Oder hier ohne into,
okay, so.
Und jetzt sage ich hier m into,
das funktioniert, einmal funktioniert das.
Aber wenn ich es vorher schon mal gemacht habe, dann...
Äh, okay.
Achso, muss ich sagen, U8.
U8.
Super, Angel.
Und dann funktioniert das nur ein...
Oder auch nicht.
Ah, guck, guck.
Das meinte ich, genau.
Genau, weil man das nicht kopieren kann, wenn ich das hier einmal umgewandelt habe, kann ich das hier nicht nochmal umwandeln.
Das ist Rust-Logik jetzt an der Stelle.
Das heißt, dafür brauche ich dann...
Arrive...
Copy, ne?
Ups.
Ich kann ja tippen
Der Rife
Jetzt können wir sagen
Copy
Copy und Clone, ja, meinetwegen
Oder
Copy und Clone
Weil jetzt funktioniert es
Jetzt clont er sich das oder kopiert er das?
Was ist der Unterschied?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Copy und Clone?
Kann ich nur Copy implementieren? Geht das auch?
Ja
Copy und Clone
Jetzt funktioniert das nämlich.
Weil jetzt ist Rust so schlau und sagt,
okay, ich kann das hier nicht
umwandeln, weil das schon hier
umgewandelt ist. Jetzt mache ich quasi
eine Kopie davon und die wandle ich jetzt in U8 um.
Ah, so ist das.
Interesting.
Verstehe.
So.
Ah.
Ja, ja. Okay, okay.
Es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert. Ich bin begeistert.
Wir können unser
Device resetten damit.
Sehr gut.
Da haben wir doch was gelernt, oder?
Hm.
Wo ich mir noch etwas
unschlüssig bin, ist, wie wir das Ganze jetzt
gruppieren.
weil wir müssen ja hier in das modul das irgendwie rein hauen also wäre wäre es nicht sinnvoll dieses
ding hier zum beispiel zu nehmen und dann sagen wir machen wir lassen das war die idee machen
okay probieren wir mal aus und wie gut roger das kann refactor und zwar wollen wir es musen nach
End. Okay, mein Auto
Complete ist ziemlich am Abspacken.
End Plus.
Ach, End Plus.
Und dann
End Message.
Ist das, nennt man das so?
Ist das
richtige Rust
Benahmung?
Was man jetzt sagt hier?
End Plus.
Achso, vielleicht sollte man es auch gleich noch richtig benennen.
And plus Message Type.
Dass das hier reinkommt.
Also, nennt man die Datei so?
Wobei ich eigentlich and weglassen könnte, weil der Ordner schon so heißt.
Oder?
Rename.
Dass wir quasi dann sagen können, Message Type.
So.
Ja, Rust
Rust hat schon irgendwie was
So, und jetzt muss ich dann aber hier
sagen
Public Mod, dass es
exportiert wird
Jetzt kann ich sagen
End Plus
Das muss ich
dann importieren, weil ansonsten wäre das
ziemlich doof
Hä?
Moment
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt
Äh, Moment, Moment, was?
Warum muss ich das jetzt doppelt schreiben?
Was ist denn das?
Ah
Weil, hä?
Ach so
Ja, ach so, weil das müsste sonst hier drin sein.
Kann ich das irgendwie re-exporten, dass ich das so nicht schreiben muss?
Weil ich hätte den Message-Type am liebsten hier unter M plus hängen.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Man könnte es ja auch einfach importieren, oder?
Man könnte es einfach importieren
Und dann ist gut
Wie unresolved import
Was ist an dem import jetzt unresolved?
Achso, weil es nicht end message heißt
oder MessageType, lol, ich hab's ja umbenannt.
Ey, hä?
Jetzt ist richtig. Use, create, endpost,
MessageType, MessageType.
Jetzt ist gut so.
Okay,
Funst, alles gut.
Mich würde jetzt wirklich noch interessieren, kann man das irgendwie
re-exporten? Also, dass
ich quasi sage, okay,
PopModMessageType ist okay,
Aber dass der das dann quasi so...
Okay, lass mal kurz.
Rust Pub Mod.
Was ist hier drin?
Use Message Type?
Ah.
Nicht Public Mod.
So.
Aber das muss ich Pup machen, ne?
Pup Use Message Type.
Sonst machen wir das mal weg.
Und jetzt ist es
End
Plus
Da hab ich's irgendwie verkackt hier.
Ah, ja sehr gut.
Gut.
Ja, ich frage ja manchmal auch KI.
Aber gerade wenn ich was neu lerne, ist das eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Ich probiere selbst ein bisschen rum, das kann man sich auch viel besser merken.
Du kannst 15 Mal eine KI immer das gleiche fragen, bis du es irgendwann merkst.
Oder es selbst einmal verstanden haben.
Und wenn ich was neues lerne, bevor sie es erst mal verstanden haben.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut jetzt.
Ah, wir können mit unserem USB-Stick reden.
Und noch besser, und noch besser.
Guck mal, wenn ich jetzt Release mache.
Ups, äh, Blödsinn.
Da muss ich das anders machen.
Ja, Sudo, Cargo, Run, Minus, Minus, Release.
Guck mal, dann kriegen wir die deutlich reduzierte Log-Ausgabe.
Sehr schick.
Exquisite.
So soll das sein.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut, Leute.
Excellent.
Macht das Sinn, so wie ich das hier aufgeteilt habe?
So, ich meine, wir müssen dann, aber das machen wir irgendwann in einem anderen Stream,
das hier noch irgendwie ordentlich in irgendein eigenes Truck packen.
Vor allem müssen wir dann auch das Response ordentlich parsen und sowas.
Das kriege ich jetzt heute in 9 Minuten nicht mehr hin.
Aber das finde ich so schon mal ganz nice.
Was gibt es denn noch so für Dinger?
Die ich brauche.
System Reset, Message RF, was auch immer das bedeuten soll.
Wir hatten doch hier noch ein paar.
events was gibt es denn was haben wir hier die feind a4 acknowledge
das haben wir nämlich gerne drinnen
ja okay ja was was was braucht man dann noch für dinge das weiß ich ja noch gar nicht das
Das müssen wir dann später mal gucken.
Also die Checksum kommt auf jeden Fall hier auch schon mal raus.
Die können wir dann tatsächlich einfach mal hier reinpacken.
Ach, Checksum.
Wobei, muss ich das...
Moment.
Muss ich das hier Papp machen,
wenn ich es hier
schon Pup habe.
And plus
Ja, muss ich.
Also heißt es im Endeffekt, das muss Pup sein,
sonst wird das nix.
Äh.
Was zum Teufel?
Achso, weil ich ein N-Plus-AS habe
und kein Mod-AS.
Okay, das ist natürlich unglücklich.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte
im Endeffekt wieder sowas hier.
Ah.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber es würde funzen.
Ah, okay.
Ja, nice.
Chat.
Haben wir doch schon einiges auf die Reihe gekriegt, ha?
Wir lesen, wir schreiben in unseren USB-Device ein Reset und bekommen eine Antwort, eine Response zu dem Reset zurück.
Hier unten.
Jetzt, jetzt noch was anderes.
Ich habe jetzt noch fünf Minuten Zeit.
Ich benutze, ich benutze hier dieses Debug-Makro.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so das Tolle.
Wie kann ich nicht sagen?
Tracing.
Debug.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Das wäre schon mal ganz okay.
Das funktioniert nicht, weil es gemovet wurde.
Richtig?
Rust?
Nein.
Aber weil das Display nicht implementiert.
Jetzt müsste das schon mal was ausspucken hier unten.
Aber nur im Debug-Modus.
oder die marktmodus der haut so viel ich raus da erkenne ich ja gar nichts mehr
ach hier ried ok 5 bites
So und wie mache ich das jetzt
Für
Meinen Buffer
An der das geht das
Kommt da jetzt was sinnvolles bei raus
Ja aber falsch formatiert
Und wenn ich jetzt an der Stelle
Ja, super.
Max, ich habe durch dich übrigens vor geraumer Zeit angefangen, Go zu programmieren. Sehr gut.
Du hast die Sprache mal irgendwann in einem YouTube-Video empfohlen.
Jetzt habe ich so eine Herzliebe zu der Sprache.
Ja, Go, das beschreibt mein Verhältnis zu Go auch ganz gut.
Es gibt kaum eine Sprache, in der man so schnell und auch wirklich sehr brauchbar Sachen auf die Reihe kriegt.
Aber Go fuckt mich zwischenzeitlich immer ab.
Zum Beispiel, was mich in Go abfuckt, ist, dass Go in der Standard-Library nicht sowas hier drin hat.
zum Beispiel, guck mal,
wenn man, wir nehmen jetzt mal Rust
als Beispiel, könnt ihr auch C Sharp nehmen
oder Ruby nehmen, ist vollkommen egal.
Wenn ihr hier einen Vektor habt mit Zahlen drin,
und ihr wollt in Go,
also, ihr habt hier jetzt
Zahlen, wir machen es jetzt mal auf Deutsch,
macht man nicht, damit fangen wir jetzt gar nicht an.
So, ihr habt hier ein Array, kann man sagen,
ihr habt ein Array mit Zahlen.
Ihr wollt es jetzt filtern und nur Zahlen,
die größer 5 sind, rausfiltern.
So, in Go
müsst ihr so machen, guck mal,
in Go müsst ihr eine Vorschleife
darüber machen und dann müsst ihr
ein If machen und sagen
X größer 5
und dann
hier irgendwas mit X machen.
Und das ist tatsächlich,
wenn ihr sogar
eine Collection haben wollt,
die da drin ist, dann müsst ihr in Go sowas machen.
Keine Ahnung, N Result,
ich mache jetzt mal Pseudo-Go-Code,
Append
X zu Result
und ich glaube in Wirklichkeit geht es sogar so.
Irgendwie so ist die Go-Syntax. Kriege ich gerade aus dem Kopf nicht hin.
Also das ist super eklig.
So, in anderen halbwegs gescheiten
Programmiersprachen
kann man sowas hier machen.
Ja, Filter
X größer
5. Zack.
Und hier Result.
äh, x größer 5.
So, das ist das, das ist im Prinzip
das Gleiche, wie
wie in Go.
Ja, das stimmt. Und es gibt
auch ein paar ganz gute Libraries mittlerweile für
für Go. Es gibt zum Beispiel
links, ja, wie hieß das? GitHub?
Lo?
Das da. Guck, das
hat so ähnliche Dinger. Da kannst du
in Go, kannst du dann auch sowas hier hinschreiben.
Auf.
Lade die Seite.
Ja, da kannst du da auch hier sowas hinschreiben.
Hier Unique, bla, blub.
Und die haben dann auch sowas wie hier Filter.
Dann sagst du hier Low, Filter, blub, blub, blub.
Ja.
Es ist immer noch ein bisschen ekliger als in anderen Sprachen.
Aber.
Immerhin geht das jetzt.
Ja, also ich finde das hier in Rust.
oder C-Sharp mit Link ist da ganz
vorne mit dabei.
Mittlerweile mit diesen
View-Geschichten
in C++ gibt es ja
auch was, was in die Richtung
geht, wobei es halt wieder typisch
C++ der größte Bullshit überhaupt ist.
Aber das ist schon nice,
dass das so easy geht. In Java hast du
Streams zum Beispiel, in Java machst du da irgendwie
sowas, hängst du die Dinge aneinander dran.
Ich glaube, oder?
Ne, ne, ich glaube da
Chancen du auch Methoden, ich weiß nicht mehr genau
Aber das ist halt, das
Fuckt mich regelmäßig in Go ab, dass es sowas
Nicht gibt
So
Chat, wir sind fertig für heute
Ich geh jetzt noch eine Runde Fernsehen gucken, dann geh ich pennen, morgen
Muss ich arbeiten
Entrer Admin Center, ne, zum Glück
Kenn ich das nicht
Das klingt nach Azure Microsoft
ade geschichte einmal plus auf ganz großen bogen träumen
ja mittlerweile gibt es eine eklige sonntags auch in c++ nur dass es halt
wieder richtig weil typisch c++ gut gedacht schlecht gemacht
Es ist schlimmer als C++
Das muss es aber schon besonders schlimm sein, ne?
Ist gar nicht so einfach
Chat, schön, dass ihr da wart
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, ich würde mich sehr über ein Follow freuen
Natürlich auch über eine Subscription
Und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream
Wir machen im nächsten Stream wahrscheinlich nicht direkt weiter
Mit Rust
sondern irgendwas anderes. Wunsch des Streams war ja auch mal, wir sollen uns ein bisschen mehr
Distro-Hopping-mäßig mal Linux-Distributionen unterschiedlicher anschauen. Da wollte ich mir
tatsächlich mal wieder Fedora für den Desktop geben, ob das taugt, weil mittlerweile soll Fedora
richtig gut sein. Das werden wir dann, ich habe es mir so überlegt, wir installieren das auf einem
Mini-PC auf der zweiten SSD.
So. Bam.
Dann haben wir Platz.
Wunderbar, Chat.
Dann. Bis die Tage.
Macht's gut. See you.
Wollt ihr noch Outromusik?
Wir haben ganz lange.
Wir haben ganz lange keine Outromusik mehr gemacht.
Wir haben schon ewig keine Outromusik mehr gehabt.
Gibt es das vielleicht auch als...
Alles klar, bis denn. Macht's gut.
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020